What a perfect time to have Lewis from unbox therapy on when our tri castors
taking a big fat shit because we updated the software and then red band decides
right before the show he's going to update his phone and it's going to take
about 17 fucking hours right in the middle of someone from the DMV supposed to
call him.
And that's never going to happen.
Now I think you guys planned it this way.
You heard I was coming down and slept less.
Causes many technical difficulties as possible and then put him on it.
Let's see how much this guy really knows.
Exactly.
Unfortunately the tricaster is a little outside the realm of my day to day.
But um,
well,
which Jamie said,
oh,
we've got to update the software.
So I go,
okay.
And then I thought that I don't update shit.
That's right.
I will wait several versions before update my phone or you know,
it always annoys me.
Apple's always asking me to update.
Yeah,
no that's,
that's certainly the move,
if especially if it's like a mission critical thing,
like your phone,
your,
your main device when you're waiting for a phone call or your try castor for
example.
Yeah.
This fucking thing.
Jamie.
Jesus Christ boy.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He was off post.
We have no video right now.
Well,
it doesn't matter.
The video's not unused stream.
It's not even going live,
so you fucked it twice.
It's double fuck.
Terrific.
Folks,
if you,
if you're doing this right now,
enjoy the blackness.
Yup.
That's what all black lives matter,
including the black lives coming out of the fucking screens.
How dare you.
Jamie didn't even test this shit out.
How dare you anyway,
for everybody looking at a blank screen right now,
like me,
I'm looking at the blank screen,
uh,
most of the people unfortunately for you or audio only anyway,
so.
Oh,
that's true.
Yeah.
Listen,
after the fact.
Unbox therapy though,
100 percent video.
Yeah,
very important to me.
So I can get by with audio on its own.
Yeah.
We're supposed to be showing this Jamie,
like a periscope.
It no
little side periscope angle.
Um,
well okay.
But what are we gonna do about the video?
The video's still recording on here,
right?
But it's not showing a record on here and we'll be able to put it on youtube.
And you think maybe allegedly recording.
Okay.
Allegedly.
Alright.
Nobody hears you talk.
I will.
I will draw the whole episode just in case the court reporter
trends
school tech.
So what is it you got here,
man?
Virtual realities with this is fascinating for people who can't see this.
It's virtual reality.
It's like a goggle set up with a.
on the front of it is a galaxy
s six?
Correct.
So a Samsung galaxy phone is strapped to this headset.
So the screen is your field of view.
That's right,
yeah.
And there's two lenses there,
so I'll just open it up real quick.
So the phone sits in and clips out.
Obviously you still want to use it as a regular phone and those are the lenses
that will allow you to focus,
focus in on the display at an incredibly close range.
Now the nerds out there that they talk a lot about the resolution of phones and
some say,
oh well there's no need to have a phone with a display beyond 10 80 p,
let's say,
because at this range here,
you would never notice those pixels,
but the minute you stick them in an environment like this,
just an inch away from your eyeball,
all of a sudden you can discern those pixels that you couldn't add phone usage
range.
What happens with people who wear glasses,
your glasses can fit in there.
Okay.
Yeah.
You can go with glasses in there.
Um,
there's a focus on the top here so you can actually focus them in,
you know,
depending on what vision correction,
whatever you have going on.
I've used it with glasses,
contact lenses,
so you can adjust it like a pair of binoculars.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Be.
Yeah,
exactly.
So,
um,
the cool thing in this particular case compared to like some of the other stuff
that I've shown off before,
like Google cardboard and the really inexpensive ones is that since this is
designed specifically for this device,
you get a touch interface touchpad for controlling taps and stuff and this size
here.
Yeah.
So that's just like the bottom of your laptop,
sort of like a leg,
a little little click pad,
track pad kind of situation.
So you have a little bit of interactivity there.
Um,
other than that,
I mean it,
it,
it sort of,
it sort of does what it looks like it does.
Um,
do you think we should try it out or what?
Yeah,
definitely.
Okay.
It's,
it's cool at this stuff was finally coming to light now because this was always
when we were kids,
we thought this was the future.
I think it's still is.
Oh,
it,
it just took a while for the technology to catch up to,
you know,
what we expected from it.
So I'm going to get it.
I'm going to get it set up here.
Okay.
Let me just,
I got a call from Duncan trussell once he came back from some conference that
they had on virtual reality and uh,
I'll never forget this because I'll stand in front of the Improv and he's
screaming,
dude,
this is bigger than the fucking wheel.
Bigger than the Internet.
It's bigger than everything,
man.
This is a fucking game changer,
dude.
It's a fucking game changer.
It's the virtual reality.
It's what the future is.
He had just gotten
back from la checking out the newest oculus rift.
The one that you were talking about,
the piano demonstration.
Yeah.
So that one.
Is the mic here.
Sorry,
I can't see anything anymore.
Um,
so,
uh,
this one was built sort of in conjunction with Oculus.
So there is an oculus store and library app that you boot into when you put the
phone into the,
into the headset.
So a lot of the demos that are available on Oculus are also available here.
So I'm going to bring up.
I'll bring up that one with the piano and then I'll let you check that out.
Oh,
you can do it right from that.
Yeah.
So that's as good as oculus rift.
While I wouldn't go that far,
I would say it's more convenient than oculus rift and probably arguably more of
a game changer in the sense that people don't have to go out and buy these
standalone expensive headset and then have a dedicated pc to use it.
Everyone has a phone.
Right?
So you're already halfway there.
This fear doesn't have a phone anymore.
Oh,
I heard about that.
Do you feel about that when someone fucking completely bales,
since you're such a technical job?
I have,
um,
for folks who don't know where you're talking about already should fear,
gave up on smartphones,
just uses a flip phone.
I kind of get it because I feel like I'm so immersed in,
in tech sometimes that I would love to take a step away for a minute.
Like,
you just booted that phone up.
You said you hadn't booted it in a while.
Texts were coming in and.
Yeah,
exactly.
It's a,
I mean it would be really a really interesting experiment to see like how many
times that thing interrupts my day.
Like a smartphone because it's probably,
I don't know,
a thousand times maybe like it's,
it really has,
it really trains you like a,
like a,
a buzz collar on an animal or something like that.
So anyway,
you want to stick this on and check it out?
Sure.
So it looks cool for people who would just listen to at home.
It looks like something storm troopers would wear plastic and uh,
you can strap so you can tighten it.
I don't know if you feel
it's a good look on you.
I think something came off.
Yeah,
it just goes,
it just slips through note right there yet.
Just like a pair of.
Yeah,
just like a pair of.
Yeah.
Oh I see.
It's like a pair of ski goggles pretty much.
Now you said this also has bluetooth so you can hook up like headphones
wirelessly also.
Right.
So every capability that the phone has is still theoretically active,
you know,
so are you focusing in yet?
So try and find the spot where the text is a text on screen right now.
Touch the touch pad to resume.
There you go.
Are you in that space right now?
That's better.
It's better with sound,
but it's still pretty good.
And if you,
if you kind of watch this guy play the.
See if you can find the dog.
Yeah.
Yeah man.
I
chose people who are just.
They don't know what I'm doing here.
I'm looking around the room.
At first I'm just looking at this guy played piano and it's kind of cool.
Although he is a little annoying.
I don't like to waste things.
Do you see the smoke?
Do you see the smoke coming off his cigarette in the ashtray?
No,
it's beside the piano there.
Yeah,
it's slightly pixelated.
I wouldn't say it's perfect.
Yeah,
it's,
it's not high resolution,
but I heard that the Oculus version is when you pitch,
it looks at you every now and then.
This is so fucking strange.
I'm looking around this guy studio.
He has this,
uh,
recording studio here.
I'm just kidding about him.
Annoying me by the way.
I'm just trying to be funny.
And then he puts his phone in his ashtray.
Let's throw in shit on the ground.
I guess he's acting.
He's acting.
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
no,
he knows what he's doing.
He has a three 60 camera there,
but he's got a fake tree in his room and as you look around his studio,
like everywhere you look you can see stuff.
This is the real.
What's really a game changer about this technology is that it's really 360
degrees.
Yes.
Like as you,
as you look,
everywhere you look,
there's something to look at [inaudible] and that is fucking strange man.
Yeah.
If they do this with movies,
to watch movies over and over again because you'll,
you'll be able to look at it from different.
Okay.
Now I see the smoke a cigarette.
There you go.
I have a feeling he makes really whiny music.
While you're probably right,
to be honest,
I really wasn't listening.
It was more about the visual.
Yeah.
I'm kind of glad I can hear him saying.
But uh,
there's another one in there,
another demo,
which is you sitting inside a movie theater and so you see the,
the,
the seats around you as the trailer plays on the make believe movie screen,
the colors coming off of it are reflecting off the seats and it gives you an
incredible feeling of the exact vibe of being inside of a theater.
I have the original oculus left and that was one of my biggest,
what I say lift that uh,
it was really pixelated.
I get the idea how cool it was.
Now,
is that comparable to that or is this more many levels better?
Better than that one.
Put it on it's many levels better than the pixelated one that Duncan had.
Duncan has a series of one which was like A.
Wow.
Yeah.
I think they were like vga screens for some.
I might be wrong about that,
but yeah,
playing doom.
Yeah,
the old school day.
yeah,
yeah.
But you kind of got a sense that this was a game changer.
Yeah.
Because even though it was so pixilated like,
well though,
they're going to work that out.
They're going to try and walk around.
This is dangerous right now.
Yeah.
Don't walk into the TV.
Just stand still.
Yeah,
the dog looks cool.
Yeah.
Don't talk off mike either.
Ready to touch your dog.
Yeah.
It's.
And the thing and you know,
part of the conversation here is about content too.
It's like,
well,
how does stuff,
how do you go from having a piece of video and turning it into 360 degree video
like he's watching right there and we're seeing more and more.
Three 60 cameras come out now.
There's a one from Google called jump,
which is this crazy gopro contraption you may have seen.
It's a six or more a Gopro hero fours,
which have an incredible field of view.
And then softwares.
What stitches it all together,
which is the experience you're seeing in there.
So theoretically it's not just a,
um,
games and digital things,
but uh,
in the people will shoot video in three 60 and enjoy it in place.
Yeah,
that's what I was saying.
Like they can do that with movies like and you could see the same movie over and
over again and you'll decide to go outside.
You'll decide to go on the porch,
you know,
you'll decide there'll be seen.
It's like you go on the porch and the wife and her sister are going to be
fighting like that.
I'm fucking leaving him.
I can't take it anymore.
And the guys in the bathroom shooting heroin will peak in the bathroom.
We're shooting heroin,
you know?
Yeah.
Like why I chose that scene.
Sounds pretty intense.
But yeah,
let you choose your own adventure type scenario mysteries where you're like
opening up cupboards to look for like little pieces of if you like watching it
at home.
Especially if you can actually move around like on a unit directional.
If you get one of the unit directional treadmills that operate based on union
your movement.
Yes.
They're getting better and better with those.
They used to be.
You got strapped in.
Yeah.
I've tried one.
Kind of hold onto the thing,
but they're getting better.
Yeah.
And now I think they're developing ones that are detecting which way you're
standing and walking,
so they will move accordingly with you and then eventually they'll get to a
point where it's going to be indistinguishable between walking outside and
walking on this unit.
Directional Readville yeah.
As long as everything's flat.
Once you start going uphill and then rugged terrain,
things are going to be.
That's not going to work.
Kind of adjustment.
Yeah.
Like hiking.
Like you'll,
you're never really going to be like,
you know,
the grounds off a little bit.
Part of the thing though about it is like I think a lot of people who are into
this for consumption are lean back type situations anyways.
Right?
Like it will be like having an exercise show on television.
I mean,
how many people actually participate compared to just want to sit there like
prevention of those that Denise Austin.
You remember her?
Yeah.
They used to have all these like you'd work out along,
like get up there on xbox now.
Do you remember the Israeli guy on the beach was always really ripped.
No handsome guy.
Black hair.
He's to have this workout and get everybody pumped up.
You don't remember.
I don't think I've ever watched Jane Fonda,
Jane Fonda,
she had videotapes.
Imagine if you got into the videotape business like couple days ago,
like I'm a fucking set the world on DVD.
I watched the DVD last night and I forgot the resolution on those are shit when
you're watching on a big screen.
I've never realized regular,
regular duty for 80.
I got an email from a company that was offering to transcode all of my youtube
videos into dvds.
So like,
yeah,
I'm probably good.
We'll get it.
Set him off smoke.
So
it was like this huge spiel about how the DVD market is not dead yet.
And he could,
you know,
you could serve as people who don't have connectivity or something.
It looks like it's working,
Jimmy.
Yeah.
Look,
Hooray.
You figured it out.
You fuck.
Go Jog.
Yay.
We're here.
Yeah.
So we're alive allegedly for now who knows?
He might not be working.
So this is like maybe one step in this ultimate 3d reality reality where yeah,
where consumption for us turns into this.
Um,
this three dimensional thing instead of two dimensional,
we dealt with two dimensional now for what?
A eight 70 years or however long a black and white long man.
I really stop and think about it.
I mean it's probably been more than that because what was silent movies?
There was the 19 tens.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
maybe tens.
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
But think about the amount of time it wasn't that like 19.
Oh,
four or some crazy shit.
That would be amazing if that's true.
The earliest silent movie.
I mean,
but before that they had still images.
Right?
So you had photographs and they went from photographs
one.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ.
Where we off?
Holy Fuck Man.
Wow.
That was um.
Oh,
that's just the first one.
Well the first one,
um,
the first talkie was the jazz singer in 1927.
He imagined like in Nineteen,
27 people sat down like jogging because they had audio now.
Wow.
And they probably had a sync it up.
Oh,
you remember?
That was like always the big thing with a right movies that were sinked up bad.
The sound was linked up to the lips didn't match.
The still happens now is go to youtube and there's a video.
We can't show it.
Can we show it on this?
Oh,
it's still fucking up.
Okay.
Not when is Nosferatu when?
I want to say Nosferatu was like early,
early 19 hundreds,
but it might've been yet 20 to 22,
19,
22 fucking dope movies still to this day.
Like that vampire was a good vampires for back then it was like they did it and
they couldn't show much back then because it was obviously it was black and
white,
but it's also if you look real close you'd be like,
what the fuck?
The makeup,
that long creepy fingers.
And he was like some prominent actor of the time if I'm really.
I think so.
I don't know.
Maybe I'm no expert,
but yeah,
I bet he was.
I mean,
but look how fucking they really did a good job.
I'll pull this up here.
That was,
that's a creepy,
very creepy.
Very creepy.
I mean when you think about 19,
2010,
what?
Limited technology they had in some ways.
I mean,
you really have to appreciate what it used to take.
Oh yeah.
I was on the set of independence day to which they filming.
Is that a thing?
Yeah.
I don't know if I was supposed to talk.
Independence Day to just heard about this famous,
right?
Yeah,
I'm Hemsworth.
Uh,
there's two Hemsworth,
right?
Thor?
Who was thor?
Liam.
There's Liam and there's another.
Chris is a brother.
They're brothers and they're both.
Both.
Hansen was fuck.
Yeah.
Unbelievable.
I like that guy.
No,
no.
See I would splurge for him to be the leading men and independent states as
well.
We must save the world just like Florida.
Basically.
It was beautiful hair,
but anyhow,
I went there and I mean we shot like we shop for 13 hours for about 20 seconds
of what it'll actually be in the film and everything is blue screen.
There's nothing around you anywhere.
They spend a say a year shooting it and then another year in post production
just painting everything in artificially.
So it's,
it's,
you have to kind of appreciate that.
Back then if they wanted something,
it had to happen.
Then we had to do it right there in the art,
you know?
Oh,
like makeup.
Yeah.
Patrick Mcgee.
He's the guy who made that American Werewolf in London out in the lobby that
that guy was like when I had them on the show he was talking about like,
those days are kind of going and it sucks because when you look at like fake
monsters in movies,
like perfect examples,
like hose underworld hawks,
a good example to the underworld.
Werewolf's yeah,
like they look so vague but kind of cool.
It's cool,
but it's video game.
It's like in a different.
Yeah,
it's cool,
but you don't think you're looking at a real thing like the twilight werewolf
guys when they turn to the wolves and twilight.
You like get the fuck Outta here.
That does not look real.
You know?
It just doesn't look.
Even if it's bad,
as long as you're looking at a real thing,
it's not as offensive.
Like the creature from the black lagoon.
It's Kinda bad.
But you're looking at a real,
like a lighting thing where you can.
With the CG you can tell it.
It's almost like the shadows and reflections are kind of off a little bit and
even if you're dealing with poor costume or um,
well I mean that thing out there is perfect.
That's better than any CGI.
You're going to possibly bad around it though.
The getting better at it and like the wolves and game of thrones or like the
closest to a real animal and they still,
they still,
yeah,
they still suck,
but there's the kind of get a real wolf wolf or they don't listen,
not listen.
It's a great friend who has wolves and they're,
they're cool animals but you are not telling them what to do because it's not
happening.
And maybe they'll sit for a second if you give them meat,
but they're on their own little trip.
There's no,
there's no evidence ever.
If somebody's having trained one will you train them?
But you don't train them like a dog.
Like they're fucking.
Like when I went to his house it was like,
Whoa,
these are not dogs like they did looking at you,
they're checking you out.
And when you,
how the,
how with you.
Like I will go into his living room.
They just can't help it.
They can't help it.
They just have to fucking house shits do that.
Shits is.
Yeah,
because they're like wolf reeling from the Wolfe family are hilarious.
Dogs to dogs are more closer to the wolf I guess if that's true or not.
Huskies look like a fucking wolf and they're weird band.
There's a weird animal.
You can't.
They like this guy that had them.
I saw a guy walk into the other day,
some old dude and he had a,
they had those face things on them to protect their josh shot where they call
those things must a muzzle muzzle.
They were muzzled to keep their,
uh,
their face from biting people.
What's funny is they have this new thing if we had the internet,
which show you,
they have these new muscles that look like rabid angry werewolf faces.
So like when they put the muzzle on the dog,
that dog looks like it's about to attack you.
That's not a good move.
That's not.
Couldn't move at all because then you have the dog in the park people.
Yeah.
It was just an asshole if you see it,
if you got
dogs hardcore.
That's really funny.
If you said it would be funny,
it was a smiley face.
Smiley.
Yeah.
Um,
but uh,
this dude who had the wolves,
I always felt it was like super irresponsible to have them.
He,
his wolves got out and they killed a bunch of the neighbors sheep.
He lived in Texas to spread in Texas.
Like his family had a ranch and he'd go out to the ranch,
brings dogs,
sometimes dogs in quotes.
There are seven eights,
wolf,
one eighth dog because you can't own 100 percent wolf I guess,
but you know,
and like,
like really,
really high bizarre.
As you get those people with cheetahs on their couch.
I'm sure you could own them as you went to those places.
There's some states like Texas has some crazy laws in Texas as you could fucking
seat.
There's everything in Texas.
They have all these African animals on these high fence hunting operations.
You can go and hunt just like you're in Africa.
You can hunt like oryx and linens and all these giant fucking African Savanna.
Animals landed the free.
Yeah.
They have a bunch of different muscles.
I guess it's a little tiny dog.
Yeah.
It's Kinda cute if it's a plug.
And then there's like,
here's the one I was talking about,
like there's,
they have like crazy looking ones where some are more realistic than you find
out about something like this because there's a little dog.
Yeah.
Oh,
okay.
I was thinking if you went from,
does your dog bite?
No.
If it did,
you wouldn't even know what's going on down there.
I'm getting bit by a dog.
What the fuck?
I'm so anyway.
I don't know how the fuck we got onto the subject of wolves.
I think it was all CGI.
Cgi.
Yeah.
There is that with the,
what do they call it?
The um,
something valley,
the uncanny valley with people like when they show people a Nvidia had a
demonstration and we went to it and uh,
one of the cool things about the demo was you could see what they can't get yet.
They can get high balls,
they can get skin,
they're really good at,
but they can't do eyelashes,
hair and they can't do it.
Yeah,
heres bad.
The guy that and the thing was bald and they can't do tongues.
Tongues look fake too.
So while the guy was talking,
there was no,
no tongue,
like you didn't see his tongue.
So fucking weird.
It was like a few things,
a computational thing when you're dealing with something so refined like strands
of hair for example,
in each one behaving independently,
like long here,
thrashing around is like incredibly complex piece moves.
So you would need some incredible hardware to be able to replicate that.
But that said,
it's never stopped the progression in the past.
I mean,
I got this a retro console the other day that plays Nintendo Games,
so I could be like a hipster and play the original Mario and whatnot.
And uh,
it's just amazing that in my lifetime we've already gone from a little guy who's
like eight pixels total as your character in the game to,
to what we're working with now.
There's some clips on youtube of people who have taken a grand theft auto clips
and applied intense shaders and things to them.
Have you seen?
Yeah.
It's pretty amazing what they're doing.
Did that they.
They used a goddammit.
I just glanced at the article real quickly,
but they used like the final scene in the show and imported it into a video
game.
Oh Wow.
Yeah.
God Damn it.
I haven't seen that.
It's probably grand theft auto,
grand theft auto maker or whatever that they released is pretty intense.
You can build your own levels and things,
movies and stuff,
so maybe that's what it may be.
Mods and you're talking about how that some the modern one.
Yeah,
where they've taken like Pixar textures and just took it to the next level so
you're looking at it.
It's a very slow frame rate because again,
coming back to resource intensive tasks,
but you can get a sense for what that will be like and so like bringing it full
circle back to back to this thing here.
I think that the more accessible this stuff becomes so the.
The cheaper that vr gets and the less that it's tied down to anything,
the smaller that it gets,
the greater the likelihood that there'll be a enough demand that people will
then go and produce cool content for it.
But um,
which phone is that?
That's the Esx,
this Samsung the six.
You can also get this headset for the note for right now.
For some reason,
those two.
This is the newest one that they make.
There are also a generic branded ones that you can slip any phone into.
The only issue that arises from that is how do you,
how to interact with it.
Like you have these weird switches or buttons.
Sometimes you don't have a nice touch pad like this one.
So that's the only thing to consider.
An htc also make one that's pretty,
like the vive.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a standalone headset.
Yet people are saying great things about that.
I haven't tried it yet.
Uh,
but every manufacturer is apparently interested in it.
And I've been noticing more and more uploads on Youtube.
It's amazing how Youtube has pushed not not just this,
but like also four k I upload my videos and in four k for example,
they are there for you.
You have these giant productions for television shows and you can't get that
content in four k.
it's bizarre.
It's like they spent $100,
million dollars.
Well,
in the case of house of cards,
you could get it in full Rez,
but anyway,
you've been able to do that on youtube for a while.
Now you're getting three 60 video on youtube.
I don't know if you've checked any of it out.
I haven't checked that out,
but the Fort K's interesting because like the new apple box,
they're saying the new apple TV that was announced last week,
supposedly it doesn't run fourK ,
which I thought was interesting because is it just that they're not pushing the
four k to the masses yet?
Because I,
I honestly,
I think it comes is a bandwidth issue.
You can,
a connection issue.
Everybody is sort of held up by the terrible telcos situation that exists here.
Uh,
I did some research recently on like Internet connections around the world and
like North America,
he's insanely bad.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's quite surprising comparatively like country Korea,
Korea's insane,
south.
Crazy,
insane.
But even countries you wouldn't expect like Romania or Latvia,
like some of these countries that I sort of often converse with my audience
members and they're sending me,
they send me their speed tests and then tell me what they're paying for it.
And you get,
and I'm sure there's plenty of people listening here that are going to start
tweeting out their speeds.
Let us know how fast your Internet is and what you pay for it.
But in Korea for example,
I think like $10 gets you a 100 by 100 up and down.
And why is it,
why is it up so restricted?
In the United States we have like I have three and that's the fastest you can
read up.
Three up I think has been the fastest that I can get.
T and t uverse,
it's something to do,
and I'm not an expert on this,
but it's,
it's something to do with the cable and Dsl structure that,
uh,
there's some sort of signal loss I think associated with that where for some
reason the upload is more,
is more labor intensive,
but when you're talking about a fiber is always one by one,
right.
If it's not,
then usually it's not real fiber and in places small places with smaller
geographic areas,
it's easier to run fiber fiber from the CEO point right to the actual customers
because of the dense,
the density of people makes it worthwhile to do so.
And North America for the most part is still pretty spread out,
but google fiber is emerging in more and more cities and it's completely
overhaul and going over the top on the incumbent sort of providers,
comcast at and t,
whoever.
And the scary thing was they were trying to merge recently.
Who Was it?
Was it.
They did merge a DIRECTV.
Oh,
did they?
Yeah.
Maybe there's another one,
but I don't think that's.
Yeah,
it was time Warner and something else.
Right.
I think it was time Warner and comcast.
Yeah,
we're attempting to merge and then the FCC or whoever,
whatever party was got involved.
Well when they find out they're throttling data and fucking with people that use
Netflix and then they made a deal that they had to make a deal with Netflix and
that they could get more data because Netflix was.
There were,
there were consistently slower when people using Netflix and anything else they
fuck with people.
Oh they hate netflix.
They hate the Internet.
You know,
traditional media is always taking shots wherever they can to to sort of slow
down this thing that's happening online because they don't control enough of it.
But isn't it also because the infrastructure is just not really that good yet.
I mean they didn't really prepare for the,
the jumps in the internet usage over the last date,
decade or so.
That's,
that's true.
But there,
there are.
There are things they could have done to sort of limit the effect of that.
Like a wireless for example,
like if you're on Lte,
all of a sudden you've got 20 megabits up.
Like how is it that the wireless connections on your,
for a lot of people,
their cell phone data connection is faster than what they have at home.
Right?
Right.
But it costs you a lot of money because it's not,
it's not unlimited.
So like you could imagine that if you had put up more towers or limb or or
taking down the cost of wireless data for example,
like a lot of countries have had to skip over the.
I'm wired connections completely.
So if you're in India for example,
they completely skipped like laptops and that whole period of time there were.
Everybody was buying a cable connection or a DSL connection.
They're getting cell phones now and their primary data connection is going to be
on that mobile device and it's,
it's the same and a lot of emerging markets around the world.
So they're like investing specifically in wireless as opposed to like going
backwards and trying to make the wired thing work at all.
So that's.
So did they have like data caps on wireless?
Oh,
it's incredibly expensive.
Yeah,
that's it.
They have a,
they have data caps and they also limit things like text messages.
This is why a instant messaging apps like whatsapp are so popular elsewhere in
the world.
People trying to scoot around,
uh,
the Telcos,
it's not expensive.
It wouldn't,
it's expensive relative to what people earn their.
So what's APP,
what does that do?
It,
it lets you use the data on your phone instead of using like text message
minutes and.
Exactly,
yeah.
It lets you avoid whatever the Telcos gonna impose for the cost of a text
message.
Like a text message is incredibly small amount of data,
yet you could be traveling and your Telco could charge you twenty five cents for
each one.
Well,
unless you're on t mobile,
t mobile and it,
it's,
it's really bizarre.
Even me.
Okay.
So I'm from Toronto and uh,
and I'm on,
I'm on Roger's not a huge fan or anything,
but I'm saying comparatively speaking,
like when I traveled down here,
the maximum that I can pay over top of my regular bill is $5 a day,
maximum data calls,
whatever.
That's,
that's where it,
it's capped out at.
So you're basically using your regular,
your regular plan,
even though you're on 18 t or t mobile or whoever it is out here now.
That's,
that's relatively recent,
but t mobile came out with something that allows for you to cross the Canadian
border and the Mexican border and essentially have your exact same plan almost
in most countries.
And most of my friends just got back from Vietnam,
I think it was or or something like that.
And he said there was no difference.
He's like,
my phone worked like it was back home.
I didn't get charged a penny more.
You have to do data roaming.
Do you have to do roaming?
Do you have to turn on your technic?
Technically you are roaming.
Yeah,
but,
but do you have to call them and let them know?
No,
no,
no.
That has always been annoying about verizon.
T mobile is the way to go in.
I did a speed test last night,
a 61 down 23 up from my house where my house,
the Max is unbelievable.
Yeah.
Mobile faster than my max is three.
Three on my home.
I got three or four.
It's a DSL or cable a and t uverse,
uh,
I guess fiber supposed to be really good if the fiber.
It's not.
What's the wire that's coming in?
What are you plugging in?
Is it a phone line or a cable connection?
Cable connection.
Okay.
Yeah,
but I don't know.
I mean I thought it was fire.
I get like supposedly 50 down and you know,
for us there's no,
there's tons of marketing confusion around the word fiber because it started to
get,
like kind of become a hot term.
So everyone wanted to use it.
They wanted in their diet.
That's true.
That was too easy.
But yeah.
So,
so,
so everyone started throwing it around even though it's not the real deal,
it's not real fiber.
It's like it'll be fiber for this portion of the trip.
Right.
And then it'll go to copper somewhere in there and you have signal loss and you
end up with what you end up with right now.
What is the difference between what Google is trying to do?
Google gives zero fucks about,
about any of these players.
They know they're not trying to even coordinate with them.
They're going into marketplace is going to the the locals at least this is how
fiber worked in the early stages and saying would you be interested personally
in an insanely fast Internet connection and here's the price we could give it to
you for.
And so people within a community would sign a petition saying,
yes,
I'm interested in that.
And once they could evaluate the demand,
they're building the infrastructure themselves.
Whoa.
They have that kind of cash.
Oh yes they do.
They're skynet.
I mean think about the different shit they have now.
Oh my goodness.
So weird.
Yeah,
and it drives me how many people have their,
their info up on the cloud with Google.
Everything is there and how come that hasn't been hacked yet?
Great question.
Totally has.
Well I not yet.
Not yet.
Yeah.
Not In any big sort of immediate way.
I'm sure.
Listen,
if I had,
if you had to put your trust in somebody on the web right now,
like there,
there aren't too many parties that have been at it for this long and and sort of
had a history of success the way that Google has even apple sort of scrambling
to have web services way later than than than Google did.
I mean g mail,
people don't even think about it.
You don't even think about your email.
You're just like,
yeah,
what do you mean?
Of course it's on GMA,
like,
yeah,
it's easy.
The vast majority of people use it,
but before g mail it was like,
it was a confusing setup for email.
People used to have those little needs to have things down.
Like outlook.
Yes.
Your email from outlet,
you've got mail and you'd have to configure it every time to pop settings and
whatnot.
God,
I remember that
you'd have to put in the server.
Yes,
that's right.
I forgot about all that.
Yeah,
it was.
It was not cool.
So I think,
and we may have talked about this before,
I think their model,
the sort of ad subsidy model has driven these amazing innovations online.
Uh,
but uh,
we,
we were talking earlier when I got here about how ad blocking is like the next
big conversation for the web.
It's a big conversation with people that are youtube subscribers,
huge because youtube obviously guys like you guys like me in this show put you
put ads in the beginning and get revenue from those ads.
That's right.
If you put up an ad blocker,
those ads don't show up and then people don't get those clicks and so they don't
get as much revenue.
And so folks,
like conscientious people will tell you,
hey,
I'm turning off my ad blocker to watch your show.
And it's right just to make sure that you get,
get your proper pay off.
That's right.
Yeah.
So listen up audience,
turn it off.
Okay.
Turn it back on when you're done with us.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a significant amount of money and that's what's fascinating now.
I mean,
obviously you guys get a shitload of downloads.
You could speak on this even better than we could because for us,
the 90 percent of the people that get this show get an audio form only.
Youtube is a fraction.
There's Vimeo,
there's ustream and there's youtube and you know those are those all together
constitute about 10 percent,
but your whole thing is on like when you do an iphone video of like the big one
was when you expose the iphones were like ridiculously easy to bend.
Like that was fucking millions and millions of hits,
right?
Yeah.
Almost $70.
Billion.
Wow.
How much does a man makeup,
something like that.
How dare you
this round of about the new iphone?
Has We talk talking cars or was this a car mount or a nice watch or something?
Nice.
Something good?
Something Nice.
Nice dinner,
a nice place.
Bag of tricks.
A little fucking video will come up with this fucking thing.
The new iphone has a new material,
right?
That's not as bendable.
Have you been watching on bucks therapies?
I guess.
Yeah.
I guess I get to play with the new iphone the other day and this guy that works
for apple got.
Let me play with it and I,
I,
I would like to know what you think about it.
I think it's like the first iphone.
I'm not going to buy.
I think half the shit they showed were just software updates that this iphone
six,
normal six could do easily.
Like what?
I'm like the,
the silly thing that the touch thing.
I don't want that.
You can just push.
You could,
you could program your phone if you hold down something for two seconds.
A second menu will pop up.
Why is this like a big deal?
You know,
they made it.
What is the second?
The new one?
The new one is [inaudible] touch meaning like you push the screen like that old
blackberry that you used to have with the blackberry touch.
That was a piece of shit,
piece of shit.
The um,
what was that torch?
No,
no,
there's the one was their first screen and the whole screen push down.
It was like you would click,
click,
click.
When you make a text message,
push this thunder.
Thunder vendor is not like that shit.
Storm Storm.
That's what it was.
I hated that fucking phone.
There's a storm brewing,
but one of the biggest things was like now you don't have.
You're like,
Eh,
like if you push it down,
it recognizes that you're applying pressure on the screen so it can pop up a
second menu based on that,
but you could also just program your phone.
If you hold something down for two seconds,
they will pop up as second [inaudible].
We already have that kind of,
you know,
I don't see the big.
The phone actually physically it has a little teeny,
teeny,
teeny thing and it also has a little vibrate that's a little bit more powerful.
How often is that going to go off in your pocket?
Yeah,
like move some shit.
Your keys,
touch it,
clicks.
The other thing was that they made a big deal about how like,
hey,
we wanted to take the technology of the flash that that's on the new iphone and
put it in the front,
but then they didn't do that.
They just make the screen flash three times brighter and I used it and it did
work very well,
but for selfies,
for selfies,
but it won't,
wouldn't like get Jamie from way over there when I work for a video either,
like if you want to,
it wouldn't work for a video.
So it's kind of like they're kind of side talking like,
Hey,
we want to put this flash,
but now we found no,
well it's whenever they have an s they don't go too far off the original.
Sometimes some people make the argument though that with the s version,
you're getting them more.
You're getting a refinement on the first gen device,
which could theoretically have problems.
Uh,
now,
not to toot my own horn here,
but get ready for the toot.
Getting too comfortable right now.
Um,
but the video I made that got a lot of traction,
the bend test video,
um,
it sort of,
it sort of exposed a weak point in the device,
which was incredible by the way,
uh,
which was around the volume buttons.
And I managed to get my hands on a leaked component recently for the upcoming
iphone and run some tests on it and it turns out that the next generation of the
phone is going to be somewhere in the neighborhood of 60 to 70 percent stronger
because they've added zinc to the aluminum structure with the aluminum alloy,
which turns it into something they call a 7,000 series aluminum.
And that's the stuff they use an aerospace,
Nassau,
so on and so forth.
And it,
it's essentially the just way stronger without adding any kind of weight.
In fact,
the shell itself is,
was,
was a little bit lighter.
So I did this test with this crazy contraption I took just the back shell.
So just the aluminum part from the regular six.
And then from the upcoming six s and the old one bent at 30 pounds of force.
And the new one was around 80 [inaudible].
And the reason I know about the existence of zinc and I dropped that information
before apple's keynote because I went to a place called elemental controls,
which is like this super crazy scientific joint where they have this gun that
shoots x-rays into any alloy and we'll tell you exactly down to like two decimal
points,
what the elemental makeup is.
That's pretty fucking bad ass.
Yeah,
it was.
Where's that place?
It was a,
it was near the airport in Toronto,
like,
shout out elemental controls because these guys were so bad ass.
I'm like,
Hey,
I got this leaked iphone component and uh,
I might need your help.
They're like,
come down right now.
I was like,
really?
They probably wanted to know too.
They were just as pumped as I was.
They were just as mean,
you know,
a couple of old guys.
I don't their businesses normally like,
uh,
when,
when someone's doing a big order of aluminum,
like buying a boat load from China,
literally they'll tell,
sometimes scam you and say that you're getting this alloy when it might look
exactly the same as one that's Chintzy on the zinc,
let's say for example,
and so they can just go through sheets of this stuff with this gun and make sure
they're buying what they think they're buying.
What about the news glass?
They're not using the new gorilla glass on there.
It's a double,
some kind of double version of their ion x coding.
I have the glass as well at my studio,
so when I get back I'm going to be doing a preemptive scratch test to see how
much better it is.
Let's put that bitch on a target.
I'm interested.
I'm interested in that because the iphone six and the six plus I are the first
two phones that I've had,
like every single phone that I've actually cracked and I thought it was
interesting that both that also coincides with some heavy fucking drinking.
You have to think about that now.
You've been on a bender,
you talked about it on their phones.
I've been breaking like as an example,
my iphone six plus when I was getting out of my car,
it slid out of my pocket,
which was only like three feet when I'm getting out of my car.
I mean not even three feet,
two feet.
And it cracked it.
It was,
it was barely a fall.
And that seems weird.
Well,
there is a,
there's a bit of a theory on that,
uh,
about sort of the rigidity of the chassis or lack thereof that might contribute
to the glass having to bear the brunt of the impact even if you hit not directly
on it,
right?
That there might be enough flex in that,
in that aluminum will.
Speaking about like,
uh,
cases like is there any,
did they have any really good cases that have power that gives you power?
Like,
you know,
they have that aren't gigantic or they have,
they shrunk those fuckers down yet they're all pretty fucking bad listening.
If you're,
if you're already on a six plus,
that's a big phone to diet to begin with.
You throw a bad tastes on there and you're carrying a brick around.
Here's the thing,
this is my biggest criticism of what's happening happening in cell phone tech is
that they want to,
they want to make an impression on you when you come into the store and play
with the device.
So they're going to make it as thin as they possibly can.
So he come in there and you're like,
oh,
that's so sexy.
I'll take it until three days later when it doesn't make it through the day
because the batteries is so small.
The next Gen,
here's the crazy thing,
the next gen iphone,
and they didn't even cover this in the keynote.
They did not talk about this at all.
The next Gen iphone will have a smaller battery than this one.
And how crazy is that?
Wait a minute.
The one after the ass.
No,
the six s will have a smaller battery than the six.
So this is better than the success.
They will have a slight amount of battery life it like,
it's like it's like 80 milliamp hours or something like that.
Uh,
basically it means it's,
it's,
it's insignificant,
but the point being is that they're not responding to be part of the consumer
demand,
which is my demand,
which has better battery life.
I'll take.
Would you take a slightly thicker version of that?
Yes.
For double the battery life?
Well also this is not that thick.
This is nice.
Yay.
I like this that I have right here.
Like,
that is pretty Goddamn thin if you need it sooner than that.
No,
but what I'm saying,
what they need,
I mean why are they making it thin?
No,
he's saying he made it thicker,
but no,
that's not what he's saying.
What he's saying is that this new one is thinner and somehow the batteries
thinner.
Smaller,
small.
I think part of it has to do with some of the internal components taking up more
space.
Oh,
this,
like this chassis,
like what you've got here will be the exact same on the new one.
It'll be actually a little bit bigger.
It would be thicker a little bit because of these new materials because they
want it to be rigid,
more rigid.
Yeah.
So it's part of the rigidity is the adding of zinc and part of it is the fact
that they're making it thicker.
Yeah.
They're reinforcing certain areas.
So like I'm near the volume.
Why would they do that and take the battery life down?
Yeah.
Well and,
and,
but that's the thing is that they never had an s model where they've really
reconfigured the layout maybe in the next version.
But usually for the s model it looks,
it looks exactly the same.
Right?
They don't,
they don't come out with a fresh version.
Right.
There's sort of a manufacturing setup is not,
is not right for that.
So it seems so silly though because they obviously are making it slightly
different because they're making it thicker inside there.
Yeah.
They're doing their feeling is that it shouldn't look to the average person if
they pick up one or the other,
they'll look and feel the same.
But I mean,
what if you had just like this size but just a little thicker and maybe a little
more durable.
So you would need a case.
Yeah.
Well that.
Check this out.
He is that the Samsung active,
so this is exactly what that is.
So this phone here that I'm carrying is the Essex active.
This is the one that they have that's waterproof and water.
The main,
the waterproof part is cool.
This doesn't have a case on it?
Nope.
Oh yeah.
That's built in.
That's like a man's phone right there.
I feel like a man.
Yeah,
that's a tool.
That's not a toy.
What do you got there?
John?
Brian.
That's fine.
Just a comparison of like the thickness of it,
but that means it's too thick for you.
No,
no,
no.
That has a 3,500 milliamp hour battery.
That never dies on me before I go to bed.
So this is the one that's waterproof.
The whole deal.
Shock resistant dust proof.
I take.
Take it in the shower.
Just the fucking phone but.
But Shit.
Yeah,
but there's a but it is an 18 t exclusive.
Oh fuck.
What the fuck?
I know.
Terrible.
But you can do a and t t unlocked and put onto mobile.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
This is really that much better than 18 and t way better while around here.
Around here.
In my experience.
Yeah,
and also in Vegas
so you could get this unlocked and then you bring it to t mobile.
You've got to be getting a phone call.
So I'm going to fuck.
Tell him to fuck off.
We're want show.
How do I do that?
I slide it.
Slide that over.
Well that's annoying too.
One thing that I thought was weird that they did in the keynote where they said
the battery was not as strong as the six.
They said,
well,
the new operating system,
it's going to give you an hour more battery.
Well it.
Well,
but they.
I just updated the operating system on my sixth so I can an hour more battery
life on this one also.
So you're radically.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but you don't even know just up.
It's probably going to suck.
They're going to,
they're going to fuck you.
Just like they always do.
Always do software updates.
Always.
Fuck you.
Yeah.
I mean I'm never on the forefront of it.
Not on my main device to the.
I like this a lot,
so man's phone.
What's it called again?
The active active,
yet.
I like it a lot.
I've got two different time zones on there to see you.
Don't do them.
You know what time it is at home.
What I'm doing,
dude,
this is a.
it's also got a programmable button on it.
This one right here,
which you can configure as a shortcut for anything you want so you can make it a
voice recorder.
Like if cops were fucking with whatever your favorite thing to launches.
Yeah,
making launch anything instantly from there.
If a girl band is trying to get arrested and explaining how she's about to try
to get you arrested.
Red.
Probably a good time.
Calls nine one one.
No,
I called nine.
Alright,
let's get off that.
I liked the topic yet.
I like that phone a lot.
Yeah,
so this is kind of really frustrated.
The apple thing.
That's just one thing though.
We're talking to a lot of shit about apple here.
I think that there's one thing that remains to be seen and that's the camera.
The camera on and next model will be an improvement.
I'm 100 percent positive.
It's a 12 megapixel.
It's going to shoot four k and apple knows it.
The camera has been the battle ground of smart phones for the last five,
six years.
If you have the best camera,
you're going to cell phones and the prom for apple right now is they don't.
There's no argument that the s six camera is better.
Oh,
I guess you could make an argument.
Subjectivity,
color representation,
blah,
blah.
The Essex shoots better photos than the current iphone and that's a big problem
for them.
So I fully suspect.
So the galaxy s six is what you're talking about.
Yep.
So people that are listening to this
garden.
Yeah.
How perfect is it?
Six s and the six.
Those are the competing products,
the iphone and the galaxy s six.
So when he says Esx,
he's talking about this.
Sorry,
what about the active?
Does it ss six active at the same camera?
Yeah.
So this phone,
let's.
I'm going to take this out for a second.
That his phone is essentially now hardcore.
You know what,
I'm glad that we did though.
You know we got right into it.
Yeah.
So this is this phone that's the same phone,
right?
Just the pretty version regular.
This is the active version.
I like the active version better at,
but you can see like form factor wise it's going,
you're going to add a little bit but you don't have to worry about dropping it.
You don't have to have a case on it.
That's right.
And Better Bank.
And you have wind.
You have like 25 percent more battery life.
Twenty five percent more than the ESX regular bases.
A $3,500,
million million amp hours.
I think this is 2,700.
So I mean I probably have my math lab but why hasn't apple smarten up and make
one of those?
I took out my old iphone one the other day and it was like this cute little
pebble in with little.
Had a little weight to it,
but I was thinking what if they just redid the idea of that making it a little
thicker and having a battery that lasts two days because it actually felt good.
I didn't care about the iphone.
I always have a case on this anyway,
so it's always slightly thicker.
Right.
Like when I feel this right here,
like this size.
This is pretty thin when I feel that though.
Yeah.
That's not like.
This is like what?
This would be with a case on it,
but this is better.
It's better to build it in like that door.
Everybody drops her fucking phone at some point.
At some point.
Why not make a phone that you can drop?
I mean we're not talking about laptops or spill on.
This is the shelter.
Big One.
Yeah.
Spills.
Spill is huge.
I've soaked that thing.
I've done.
I've put it.
I submerged completely under glass.
That's next.
Well that's the next step.
P test.
Pee test belt to blow up youtube.
This is pretty dope dude.
Yeah,
I like it.
And you can get to the Canberra right from there.
And the camera.
And this is better than the iphone camera,
in my opinion.
It is.
It just took a selfie that's on your phone?
Yeah.
Oh,
the,
the selfie camera.
Especially because it's,
it's way wider.
It's way wider.
Yeah,
it's way wider.
So you could get like two,
three people in there a lot easier.
I tried the new angle.
They new selfie camera on the new iphone.
Compared it to my.
I took two comparison shots,
one of the six and one six s and it almost seemed to be exactly the same.
It wasn't a huge deal on the front.
Facing the front facing front facing won't be a huge change.
It'll be.
It'll be all about the rear camera.
So that might be the phone to get right now.
Which one?
The s six active.
If the pro.
Here's the problem.
Most people don't buy their phones outright.
They go in,
they get a subsidy,
they sign a contract,
right?
So if you want an essex active,
you're going to have to buy it full.
Pop off a t and t if you're not on a t and t,
that's the only way.
Or people from Samsung when they don't have it already.
I don't have now because I think it's because it's an atnt exclusive.
It's kind of like a weird phone.
Fuck.
Could they not have it if they're the.
They're the hookup.
They offered us the white glove service,
the white glove service.
I do not know what's happened is nobody stays in the white glove service.
We show up at the comedy store.
They show up with phones that give us a bag and then we'll go get a little hug,
a handshake,
and it's done.
Yeah.
They'll send you a chip.
Put a little card in there.
Yeah.
It's um,
I,
I think it's a good time for phones.
I mean,
it's fascinating that everyone has to compete at this level because if you look
at the evolution of phones over the iphone one,
two,
now we're only talking about.
What was that?
Two thousand nine.
Yeah.
It's nothing that's fucking crazy.
So six years ago we had this little fat thing that lasted about an hour and that
little tiny screen and your thumb could cover the whole screen practically.
And now we have this big beautiful mini tablets,
a fablet right.
This,
is this technically a fablet or does it have to be bigger?
No,
no,
no.
I mean you could call it that.
Although China is now pushing phones that are gigantic,
so it's hard to call it seven inches.
What?
Yup.
What do they have?
Well,
they have a mega.
Samsung still does have a mega in Asia.
They love in Asia.
Huge phones in Asia.
You can't get it in America.
I don't believe so.
Not from any of the major carriers.
Crock of Shit.
There's a company,
uh,
that's emerging quickly called walway.
That does not feel good to say.
But that's the name of the company.
They're number three,
I believe right now.
As far as scale for a smartphone manufacturers,
they have various devices six inches and above,
like many a selection of them.
These things are.
Well,
I mean you can imagine.
What's the,
what's the seven inch one called?
I can't remember,
but it's giant.
I mean had many.
How big it is.
It is that size.
While the Bezel,
it's.
They've done.
Had been these nine.
Is it nine or was it 77?
Yeah,
the full size ipad is nine point seven.
They new one though.
The new ones.
There's a new one that's 12.
Right.
You might want that 12 point nine.
Well,
[inaudible] you're into illustrations and whatnot.
Right?
Right.
Yeah.
I mean with the pen,
it's unbelievable.
Yeah.
What I like drawing on paper.
You would never even consider it.
Yeah.
I would consider it because what I was saying earlier,
it's like the,
um,
the ipad pro,
the upcoming ipad has the highest resolution display of anything that apple's
ever put out.
Actually.
Maybe arguably anything commercially available in the tablet space.
Phone space.
Well,
how long before someone makes a vr and slaps that suffering?
That would be,
yes.
Get a nice field of view.
That'd be perfect.
And they make this touch sensitive.
It almost seems like that would make more sense to have the ipad pro be touch
sensitive instead of using a pin that's touched sensitive.
If more people are going to draw on it.
Like this antique.
It's pressure sensitive.
I,
Syntech is a drawing pad,
uh,
and meaning it can detect the pressure.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
It almost seems like they're releasing it first on the iphone six just to,
you know,
so the ipad pro to would have it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I it.
That's a hard one for me to figure out.
I've been messing around with the note with the pen and trying my best to make
it a part of my day and it's,
it's a tough kind of.
It's a tough transition on a display this size,
but you can imagine like the pen is still far more precise than your finger
could ever be.
Right.
Your finger could never select a single pixel on a high resolution screen.
It's not a point.
So it's,
it's what's weird is like a.
If there were a little jar of ink here,
what I,
what would I choose to write with my finger,
dip it in there or the end that's decided like why did we choose in the
traditional world this and yet it seems so bizarre to carry that forward into
the digital world.
I think part of it has to do with the fact that there's no place.
There's no place for it.
You're using this thing on the go.
There's a lot of arguments there,
but when it comes to a tablet that's almost always at home,
always on the couch.
Um,
I just feel like maybe,
I dunno,
maybe this could shift the paradigm and people will look at these things as
actual notepads.
Finally,
I don't know.
I use the note five for awhile or the four,
four,
three or whatever the fear is one of them.
Yeah.
And I enjoyed the pen.
You used it.
I liked it for collecting images.
I thought it was really cool.
I could directly collect an image from,
from a thing,
and it would say save it for me and store it for me.
The fact that it was so easy to cut things and paste them and save them as
notes,
you know,
I really liked that and I really liked you draw dicks on people's faces.
That's also perfectly happy with that.
I look at my one note picture that I have in here and it's just a dick.
That was the other thing that I really liked.
It actually linked up with evernote,
so um,
when I would draw,
um,
my notes out,
I would say something,
I would write like comedy notes out and then it would it with evernote
and then I would look at it as an actual drawing as the actual me writing the
physical words.
I still have it saved up on evernote and it's,
I like it a lot.
But you don't miss,
you don't miss not having it though.
Depends.
You're right.
I don't miss it that much,
but if I,
it's not as much,
like I don't miss it as much as I like this phone better than that.
I understand what you like to see this.
I used to have them like that,
so I would draw.
That's cool.
Yeah,
I mean it saved them.
there is.
I mean there is,
there is something.
Yeah.
Then he gets through them so much easier than you could have notebook.
Yes.
And then just write it down like that.
There are definitely,
there are definitely advantages.
It's just about getting over this hurdle of usability.
It's kind of like a smart watches as well.
I don't know if you've tried any of those,
like apple watch or anything like that.
I can't get into it.
Yeah,
you get into that at all.
If I was given one,
I wouldn't be into it,
but I just can't.
It's too much money for me.
Oh well,
mine's cuts what it is.
Yeah.
For a lot of people become much more days or the one I want is about $800.
$700.
Like the Middle One's stupid one.
That's like 25 grand.
That's like made a goal.
It's around 16,000,
I believe.
What an asshole you would have to be by.
The weird thing about that too is you're going to sell a super luxury $16,000
watch.
Don't you want other people to know that it's a $16,000 because it looks exactly
like every other Apple Watch.
You know what I mean?
Like if so what is just the metal it's made out of has just made a gold.
But there's this,
there's a market for that shit.
Oh yeah.
They sold it.
They sold out in China in the first 24 hours.
You know,
there was an article recently that I read about Beverly Hills that there's an
insane amount.
Something like,
I think they were saying something will be 25 and 29 percent of all real estate
in Beverly Hills is being bought up by people from Saudi Arabia and Beverly
Hills and beverage in Beverly Hills.
Oh,
excuse me,
Saudi Arabia and China.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
And that like literally that entire area has been purchased by foreign companies
or foreign countries.
These people that have ungodly amounts of money because of oil money.
So like we went to A.
I talked about this recently,
went to the steak place Beverly Hills and there was a guy that they're importing
cars from Saudi Arabia for the summer.
They call them,
they call it Saudi summer and they come down here because in the summer there
it's 150 fucking degrees.
They come down here and they drive.
They're unregistered cars around Beverly Hills.
These million dollar,
big Gaudy Va.
Ron's.
So they have these bugatti véRonique and all these fucking super million dollar
cars with saudi plates and one and I was with my friend who's from Iran and he,
he speaks a persian and farsi and he can,
he can read arabic and farsi is what they speak,
whatever I think.
So he can read arabic and he said it says palace on it.
It said palace in the license plate.
And it said to,
to,
to like it was all twos.
So it's like the prince probably because they couldn't get one.
One,
one,
one.
One says the king.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Like this guy has fucking one point $5,000,000 car.
this isn't even registered in America.
And he's driving around and valet parking it in front of the steak place.
I'm like,
this is a,
it's a strange coopting of this area,
But I like this because it's such,
it's such a like a name place.
There's a high value to that beverly hills name.
Right.
So because of that,
like they said that some ungodly percentage of all homes,
over $10,000,000 are being purchased by rich people from Saudi Arabia and China.
Yeah.
They just scooping them up and not even living in them.
I think there's a push to sort of,
uh,
evacuate some of the money from those environments because there's an uneasiness
about what happens in the future and those economies.
So you get yourself diversified.
Yeah.
But if we're getting lucrative,
you get lucrative.
People were tweeting,
were tweeting that to me today.
People were tweeting to me that this guy tweeted to me that he works at a
restaurant and then,
uh,
all the people that work at that restaurant,
we yelling out,
let's get luke,
luke,
we begin.
I want to know where the tee shirt is because we need to make it.
Yeah.
I think there's a few people that would pick that up.
Lucrative.
But yeah man,
this,
the money that would cost for that little $25,000 watch has nothing for those
kinds of people.
And that would be the instant thing they would want.
They would want that high end thing.
It's funny you talked about,
you talked about the license plates.
I can't remember where I watched this.
I don't know if it's a documentary or just a clip about the bidding that goes on
in dubai for the specific specialized license plates like exactly like you said,
the lower than number.
So having the car isn't prestigious enough because everybody's got one that's so
they'll fucking auctions for like license plate number one,
number two,
number three,
and the,
you know,
it's in the millions of dollars because when you get to the like to the crazy
level of status and whatnot,
things get bonkers really quick,
you know,
like as far as,
as far as what,
what you need to do,
how absurd things need to be for you to make a statement anymore.
So anyways,
well in that culture,
if that's what you're going for is only like the most obvious form of material,
like rampant materialism.
Yes.
You know,
if you're,
if that's what you're going for.
Yeah,
that's what you want.
You want to get like the number one license plate.
Get him.
He's got a boot guy.
He has a $5,000,000 license plate.
There you go.
That's so stupid.
So.
Well we're act.
What if you have that much money?
Is it though?
That's the thing.
You have more money than you could ever spent,
right?
But why would you want that license plate?
That's a good point.
That much money.
And you're still trying that hard.
What kind of an environment are you competing in?
What kind of you trying to conjure up to bring into your life?
Skip point.
Who?
The.
Who are you trying to impress?
Yeah.
You already have a fucking giant yacht.
You have a giant fucking house.
You have a one point $7,000,000 car.
Does anybody look at your license plate and go look at doula?
That regular fucking license plate.
You can even afford the license plate.
Yeah.
You're not in the club.
That's not allowed in.
I.
I think it's more a thing of like in,
in order to maintain your competitiveness,
you have to keep on approaching these things.
That shouldn't be attainable like anybody working in anything.
Right.
But I think.
I think that you have to put these challenges in front of yourself,
like I got to get the extra million for the right license plate.
That's just a weird,
a weirdo version of that,
isn't it?
It is.
It's all weirdo versions because like labels are critical.
Like people want labels like very,
like someone was making fun of me because I have a lexus.
What are you going to drive an alexis for?
Why don't you have a mercedes or bmw or something like that.
I'm like,
this is a great car.
What's wrong with you?
It's like nobody's impressed by alexis.
You know,
you pull up,
that's a toyota,
you know,
japanese car guess,
but fucking so what?
Yeah,
what is wrong with people that,
that becomes a giant issue.
I don't know.
Branding,
branding,
branding.
It's strange.
It is.
Because I was in one of those.
Um,
what are they called?
The whatever.
The fucking high end.
Hyundai is now a genesis.
Yeah.
I was in one of those and I was like,
this is a fucking great car.
It feels like a mercedes in here,
but I wouldn't drive it because it's a hyundai.
Yep,
I was thinking that.
I was thinking like,
what would I draw?
I mean I probably would,
but it's.
Sunday is like a v,
it's hard to get excited about that.
Whereas at least lexus is like higher end than that.
Yeah.
Know what I mean?
Like,
so I'm guilty of the thing I'm mocking.
Really.
I think everybody is.
I think we,
I think it's a way I've said this before,
I think that the,
uh,
a person who has a certain,
you know,
certain access to a particular way of life that the shortcut,
the rich guys shortcut to buying,
to buying the right thing is to buy an expensive one.
Right?
You walk into a store,
they've got a bunch of shirts.
Which one should I have?
Well,
I can bypass the whole research structure by just buying the best,
you know,
like the average person when they're going to purchase a car,
they spend,
I think I heard this stat recently,
it's about 52 days from when they get the idea that they need a new car to the
point at which they make the purchase researching.
There's various stages throughout.
It's actually getting shorter though,
which is kind of strange.
I think the internet is getting better,
to be honest with you.
I will youtube videos on reviews of cars are awesome.
They're so critical.
Yeah.
And so I think that's really expediting the process,
but uh,
but anyway,
yeah,
I think that generally speaking,
those who have an abundance of wealth don't have as much time usually as usually
the way it works.
So you kind of try to bypass that whole process by buying the best thing and
that's where brands come in.
Brands almost help you in a way have you sort of through their prestige and
their established symbol that I know if I get that I'm good and I don't need to
ask anybody about that.
I don't need to,
you know,
I don't need to pull my friends or whatever.
It's like a,
it's like a hack.
It's the quickest way towards that.
It's like a fancy,
uh,
fancy liquor or uh,
you know,
the right cigar or in,
you know what I mean?
It's like you can find an example of that in almost every product category.
It's the same reason why samsung is samsung now.
It took so much time in so much money for that to be an acceptable brand.
They make weapons to probably.
I'm pretty sure they make weapons,
I think.
I think in Korea they make everything,
but I'm pretty sure samsung makes missiles or some shit.
Let's say samsung makes weapons.
Let's see.
You know you're probably.
You're probably right.
I know,
I know.
They make all kinds of things in Korea that never make it here.
Samsung also makes weapons checkout all they do.
Jesus christ,
they make fucking tanks.
Yeah.
Vehicles.
Samsung tech,
low tech tech when surveillance area narcotics.
This is fascinating.
Op doe electronics.
I don't know what that is.
Automations and weapons technology company.
It's a subsidiary of samsung group,
huh?
Yeah.
They make fucking weapons.
They even make jet engines.
They make tanks.
Arv is and even jet engines.
Yeah.
I mean those big technology companies got to diversify your portfolio.
Oh yeah.
Get lucrative.
Got to get loose.
That's the best way to get lucrative.
Make weapons.
People are always looking at clothes.
Shit.
It's always someone,
some part of the world.
It's like if I just had something that could blow these motherfuckers up over
there,
it'd be all good that that was the real game changer when it came to war.
Right.
Once I get to start blowing shit up and they weren't anywhere near it.
Yeah.
When london started getting bombed during the world war ii,
even world war one when they started launching bombs and using chemical gas and
essentially killing people at a long distance without having to see them.
Yeah.
And now we're even further past that.
Like really game controller in a.
Yeah.
Well that's why I wanted to bring that up.
Like the drones,
like now they're having drones.
Did you see that one guy that stitched together all those drones with some sort
of software?
Yes.
I saw that.
Like that guy's kind of bypassing all the area.
Not as rules because those rules,
like if you want to get a helicopter,
you have to get a helicopter license.
You have to,
you know,
the.
You have to tell people where you're flying.
Yeah,
we're at a,
we're in a strange point right now where technology is progressing at this
insane speed and the legal system doesn't,
takes way longer than that.
There's not enough time to go through all the steps necessary
on that side of it to catch up with the technology as it's happening.
Drones,
what was that story the other day where there were all those drones up in the
air and they couldn't,
so the helicopters couldn't get to a scene where someone needed to be airlifted.
Yeah,
they're here,
right?
Yeah.
They were using.
People were using video drones to take videos of something that was going on.
What was that?
An accident or something?
I think it was an accident in a helicopter.
Needed to get in there to pull the person out and they couldn't because of the
drums and they couldn't because of the drunk.
Yeah,
well they're going to have to have drone blockers.
The way movie theaters should have cell phone blocker,
you know,
like people are on their fucking phones and movie theaters all the time.
Yeah.
One of the most annoying things ever.
Well,
you're going to have that those block or know how you do it because.
Yeah,
I mean because it's a.
It's a radio frequency,
right?
Yeah.
It's just,
it's,
it's a rf from your.
There's going to be seeking to destroy type joint trends that you just like
throw in the air and they just go after these drones and somehow knock them out
of commission,
but you like aerial warfare over the freeway.
Drop on little kids' head.
I'm a baby gets killed by a falling drone that was taken out by a company.
Oh yeah.
I was on the beach the other day just hanging out and it was a pretty empty
beach in santa barbara and I just heard this like,
I was like,
what is that noise?
I look up and there's just a drone sitting there right above me.
Like,
I don't know,
super high up,
but you can almost barely see it.
And then it just flew away and I looked around.
I didn't see anybody growing up far.
Can they go?
No,
like a mile,
right?
God,
I mean I think it probably depends on like a military ones or do like a
personal,
not personal,
no personal one I think is still relatively line of sight like it.
You have to,
I think the minute you can't make it out is probably out of range.
Just falls out of the sky.
That's the craziest part of the drone.
People are going to get really upset with us right now,
but I don't know what the fuck we're talking about.
Not just that,
but it's a very sensitive subject matter because these enthusiasts are super
into it.
Like a lot of people in guys like us come and we talk about only the shitty part
of it,
like them falling out of the sky and killing people and they think that's going
to influence government,
which will then take away their freedom to do that thing just like everything
else.
Right?
But people that love doing something and they want to protect that freedom.
Uh,
but I,
I like,
for example,
I've done videos on these little toy drones.
They're there nothing to,
you know,
you fly them indoors or whatever.
And if you get any of the terminology wrong or you talk about them being
dangerous in any way or anything like that,
you're going to have an entire script in your comments actually in about like
that.
You're fucking it up for us.
We,
you know,
uh,
you're,
you're influencing the public opinion.
You should know what you're talking about before,
right?
You know,
they do.
They do have a point,
but so does the public at large and seeing a flying thing above their head and
wondering if the connection between the thing controlling it and it itself is
stable enough to keep it up there.
Well,
not only that,
how about the,
just the privacy intrusion.
If you're some person who's sunbathing some woman,
oh right,
you have
a fence.
You like to sunbathe naked because you're in a private,
you know you're in the backyard and no one can see in and you want to take your
top off and then get your tits tanned.
You can't do that anymore.
Who does almost four k video on your tits now on in there.
And zoom in on it.
And then also the oculus rift effect because when I was on that a scifi show,
we did some things where we took drones and we strapped cameras to these drones
and we flew over the top of these trees in the pacific northwest.
There was like looking for bigfoot episode,
were flying around looking for bigfoot with a fucking drunk.
Now obviously more of a goof than anything,
but the goggles were fucking crazy.
So you were seeing it's vision through vr yet?
Right?
So I'm watch.
I'm literally feels like I'm flying because my field of vision is just like the
vr field division.
And you're super wide angle to the camera that's attached to this drone.
Yeah.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
I mean it's going to get real,
real strange.
And again,
like you said,
the regulations have not caught up to the technology and technology's gonna move
way faster than these dummies that are making these,
these registry,
the regulations in the first place.
They don't really know what's going on.
Oh,
and how do you,
again,
how do you get a person to get to be interested in getting into government to
write these regulations?
Who's actually familiar with the thing,
like why in god's name would they want to do this at that point?
And they have to get elected.
They have to.
It's a whole process of getting intelligent people into the spot they should be
in,
is too slow,
too convoluted and the world is changing too quickly.
So the people who make the laws would have to rely on experts like they have to
hire people,
except who are those experts?
Water,
their agenda,
what's their credentials?
And essentially this young kids that haven't even graduated from high school yet
that know as much or more than anyone these people going to hire in the first
place.
Exactly.
Like these comments that you're getting these detailed comments crittenton you
think it might be from like that 14 year old kid in fucking dallas.
They got arrested today because,
uh,
his teacher thought he was making a bomb because he made,
made a homemade clock.
And.
But he happened to be making an inventing things while brown,
and that's very dangerous,
especially with an arab last name,
and especially in Texas.
His name is ahmed mohammed.
Almost as bad as barack obama,
barack hussein,
obama.
I mean,
it's like fucking for people looking for something bad.
Like,
oh,
who you know his fucking middle name.
That's,
that's a,
that's a shitty story.
It's a terrible story.
The kid got arrested with a fucking nasa shirt on.
Dude.
I noticed the ig,
that's where my head went at the exact same time when I saw the photo.
I was like,
he's wearing a neck that way.
I don't know why that stood out to me and made me especially sad.
The nasa shirt,
the kid's a genius.
That's what it is.
They say.
Yeah,
I see.
It's like,
it's his own radios.
It sort of implied a passion for the thing,
for the thing that he got arrested for.
Yeah.
Well pure racism.
It's racism and its purest form and you know,
it's just amazing that someone wasn't skilled enough to talk to this kid
socially skilled enough to go,
um,
what do you got there?
What's going on,
man?
And so he could have probably gone,
well,
I make my own computers and I make my own this.
And what I've done here is I've strung together all these electronics and built
a clock and I've figured out how to do that.
I mean,
you can easily talk to someone if you're skilled.
Oh yeah.
And was a smooth talker.
Yes.
And they would get.
And then the kid who wouldn't feel bad at all and he could probably explain how
he did it and what he likes to do.
And you'd be like,
well you are an amazing student and congratulated.
Would you mind showing that to the class and you know,
and then you've got a positive out of this instead of like,
oh look at him.
He's a little brown kid and he's making a fucking bomb.
He's trying to kill everybody.
He's 14.
It's,
how would you go look through the database?
Any 14 year olds,
suicide bombers,
these are there any that we've ever had in dallas?
Oh,
not here.
Yeah,
I mean in the middle east.
In the middle east.
They've the martyrs of.
There was a horrible fucking documentary that I watched where they had this
school and they had all these kids on the wall,
the school that were strapped up with these explosion vests and it said today's
children are tomorrow's holy martyrs.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
That's some shocking shit.
Yeah,
it is shocking shit.
This kid.
I mean it's probably the best thing that happened to this kid though.
You see the president's tweet to them,
know what the president said.
President says,
cool clock.
I made went to bring that to the white house.
We should inspire more kids like you to do science.
It's what makes America great.
We should find out who the fuck are people are that arrested him?
I don't know if that's healthy.
That's healthy for them.
They need to know what it feels like.
I know,
but the world say,
hey,
hey man,
you're.
You're on a global platform now.
You're not just in Texas like you've been doing some racial Texas shit,
but don't you feel like.
But don't you feel like sometimes the wild goose chase breeds like a weird kind
of internet violent?
Yes mentality or at least a mob like everyone let's get like the threats that
the lion killer was getting,
you know,
like I'm gonna what I'm gonna do to your children.
And it's like,
how does that,
where did we ask,
how do we escalate there?
And it's because when,
when you're in this chamber of all this noise,
people sort of elevate their level of how much of what they're willing to do to
counteract this thing that they disagree with.
Yeah.
You know,
well this is also,
there's a lot of people that are super upset with their life.
Their life is not good.
Right.
And they are looking for anything to be mad at and point their anger towards and
any,
anything that's justified,
like obviously the lion killer,
that's a nice big green light.
You know,
this guy shot a fucking lion.
It took 40 hours for the thing to die and then they had to go in and kill it on
some private,
some public property.
That's not even.
You're not even allowed to hunt there.
He had a collar on the.
Cut the collar off.
The guy was a poacher.
He has a history of poaching.
He poached a bear.
He lied about where he shot.
He shot it for like 40
miles away from where he said he did.
There was all sorts of shit about that guy that was like easy to target on.
So then the fucking hate is free.
You got a green light.
You just close your eyes and hit the gas ball.
Jared jared from subway.
That's another one,
but you know what I mean?
That's not just legit.
The being how much hate is there towards that guy?
I didn't see the kind of death threats towards jared from subway that I saw at
towards the lion killer.
I've never seen anything like the lion killer thing was to meet evidence of a
complete breakdown in social media like that was.
Have you guys ever seen black mirror [inaudible]?
The david show from the uk.
Yeah,
so I've only seen one episode.
The one with the pig got out of the first one.
Yeah,
so I saw.
Yeah.
Well that's.
That's the kind of example I'm talking about is it seems like,
but when this is the signal to noise ratio gets fucked up enough,
we sort of lose our faculties like your whole feed.
How the fuck is my.
I didn't sign up for a day's worth of line tweets.
You also have to deal with the numbers of humans that are able to communicate
freely.
That's the signal to noise ratio.
Like you talked about earlier,
that the real kicker is you used to be to be able to get on television,
you had to be walter cronkite and here's the news and you had to be an
established person who had a degree in journalism or a history as a journalist.
Now you just have to get on an application that anyone can download in two
seconds on your phone and you just start talking shit,
you know,
I'm going to come to your house.
I'm gonna.
Throw your kids into wood chipper,
like all that shit they were saying too.
That guy cory knowlton that shot the rhino at radio lab episode that we're
talking about.
I mean they said some horrible,
horrible shit to him and it's because they felt like they could and those are
the same people.
They're angry already,
like they're already angry.
This is just a nice target for that anger and it's not balanced and it doesn't
make sense and it's not,
it's not rational the,
the,
the focus of this anger,
but it doesn't have to be because you don't get to pick who you're getting that
data from like,
okay,
here's a perfect example was off us in this room and you know,
someone had done something fucked up like the lion killer guy.
We would,
we could have like a detailed discussion and how we felt about it and what are
the,
what are the actual facts about the case?
And did you know the 28 different lions wearing collars were,
have been killed.
Like it's very common.
They kill ones with the collar because once they go outside of the protected
area,
you're allowed to kill them and lions cover a gigantic area where they hunt,
so we would have these kinds of nuanced discussions because you're in a room
with four rational people,
but think about all the fucking idiots that you've met in your life.
Think about the millions of people.
If you have $350 million people in this country,
at least one out of 100 is a fucking idiot,
so that means you got 3 million,
500,000 fucking idiots to just smash and they're sloppy cheese doodle covered
fingers on keyboards
and fucking spitting on their screen and taking time to jack off in between
tweets and they smell like shit farting and wafting the fart up into their nose.
They're horrible monsters and there's millions of them.
There's millions of them,
and they will spend their whole day tweeting,
facebooking anytime something horrible goes wrong.
Now they have a green light.
I think though that it almost feels like even the intellectual web contributes
by enabling those fuck ups.
You're talking about by.
Yeah,
by by providing the steam necessary by giving them that fragment that to work
with to go with,
well just giving them a pathway to communicate with everybody.
Exactly.
So,
so an example of this would be like a media headline,
a juicy headline to get a person to click it even though as you mentioned
before,
how it would completely lack the nuance of a proper discussion or debate,
but you,
you know,
you pander to the lowest common denominator,
you want as many clicks as possible and you're not necessarily concerned with
the outcome of that,
you know,
so it's like,
it's like if we know that those big huge news sources that are supposed to or
once upon a time where it were a new nuanced or or,
or meant to,
to sort of break down the story for you to help you understand the story.
No,
it's all bites now.
It's all little fast moving bites,
hot takes and so on that formulate your opinion.
So in some ways,
yes,
those people should be held responsible for the things they say online,
but it's not like the intellectual web or the news producing web is doing the
greatest job in,
in advertising,
the proper content,
the,
the nuanced longform take it.
So it's much easier to just slam out some knee jerk type of article and get it
out faster,
be first as opposed to maybe you're a day later,
but you've had time to gather more information.
Those.
Well,
those,
the other problem is a lot of those traditional media outlets have proven to be
ineffective when it comes to controversial issues like the charlie hebdo issue,
like when charlie hebdo happened and all those guys were killed.
All those,
uh,
cartoonists were killed by those muslim extremists that came in and were mad
they were making these cartoons and mohammed,
nobody printed those fucking cartoon.
Nope.
The la times didn't do it.
The New York times didn't do at time magazine didn't do it.
Everybody backed off on tweeting those or taking photos and putting them online
or putting them in there.
Our articles,
they didn't want to do it.
So it was up to the internet and so then it becomes a matter of when something
is real and some things out there like that guy who uploaded the video of him
killing the reporters,
he killed the reporters when they were on tv and upload the video of him doing
it.
Oh right.
Yeah.
Did they ever comes?
It comes a
real weird line.
Like,
you know,
part of that discussion too was like the way we were kind of forced to ingest it
through autoplay.
This was a big part of the story was how you'll.
Facebook has recently introduced autoplay,
so you're scrolling and it just plays immediately that that's another example of
what I'm talking about,
about the,
the,
the.
I don't know that you could call facebook intellectual web,
but if you're a guy like zuckerberg or someone in that office at some point you
know that what you're doing is you're about to introduce millions and millions
of people to something they probably rather not watch.
Well that was a big deal with isis because isis has had some of the people in
isis or whatever you want to call it.
They have had many,
many,
many accounts banned because they will,
they'll find these,
they'll make these accounts,
create these accounts and start uploading photos of people being beheaded,
uploading videos and people being beheaded.
Yeah,
and they put these on instagram or twitter or wherever the hell they are and
it's up to these outlets,
these,
these platforms to find these things to take them down,
but I went to a fucking isis twitter page that somebody has sent me to and I was
like,
holy shit.
That idea.
People don't even know about it.
They hadn't even taken this down yet.
Just be headings and then there was youtube videos that are linked to that.
They hadn't found those yet either.
The youtube videos where they were shooting people on the ground and cutting
their heads off and holding their heads.
I mean,
they'll fold deal on youtube.
Yeah.
Well here,
here's my thing is I think that battle is kind of impossible to completely
control the speed at which people can put stuff up,
but the autoplay thing,
like half the choice to click the button at least at a minimum.
Yeah.
I talked about that a couple of weeks ago,
somebody posted are,
I was just like looking at puppies and stuff and then out of nowhere it was a
woman in a car accident with her face missing and she was picking out her face
and I,
it was one of the most disturbing things I've ever seen and I think about it all
the time,
you know,
like I should have never have seen that and now I can't stop thinking you didn't
have the option.
I didn't have the option.
I mean growing.
How many times have you clicked on a video and said,
fuck,
I wish I didn't click on that.
And then you learn and you know,
like I've sent you stuff and you sent me stuff.
I'm like,
I don't even want to watch that.
And you just,
you just decide,
yeah,
my life is more important now.
Imagine if every time those exchanges took place it autoplayed came up on your
phone immediately.
What they do that at facebook,
why would they rate as a great fucking reason is to,
to beef up their viewership figures.
That's stupid.
Yeah,
because then they can go to advertisers and say,
look how many views it got.
Oh,
that's gross.
it's the most gross thing ever,
and people.
The reason youtube has a lot of youtubers are especially upset with it.
It's a lot of people are free booting our content,
not mind specifically,
but a lot of other ones specifically in the comedy genre because you can take
this clip off youtube,
upload it natively to facebook,
have it autoplay,
build this huge profile for yourself based off of someone else's content that
they've made and there's an end.
There's no way for you to go and track it and facebook isn't being vigilant,
vigilant about,
about going and finding that stuff.
In some cases,
youtube as I know,
have have missed out on millions,
tens of millions of views that happened elsewhere and were associated with some
other account on facebook and there was another account they didn't may not have
even known about.
No,
they didn't.
They wouldn't know about it until somebody saw it.
That was also a fan of theirs that would then tweet it to them or whatever and
say,
uh,
there's this completely fake profile of yours on facebook,
uploading all your stuff in for today.
Get advertising revenue from that.
Well,
usually what usually the way it'll work is that they'll build up a large
profile.
So you take really funny 15 second videos so you should.
So there you go.
So you get a shit ton of followers and then every so often after you've got this
shit ton of followers,
you insert some branded thing that you're attempting to do and you're so you're
utilizing someone else's profile to build your very own it.
You're not necessarily making immediate money from it,
but you're opening up the possibility to do so after the fact.
Like he said,
with fat jew,
if,
if you've got five,
six,
10 million followers on someone else's back at that point,
it doesn't matter,
why don't you?
You can shut off the old way of doing business,
then start doing your original stuff at that point once you've already got an
audience,
right?
Right.
Well,
what fat jew did is he ca,
he took advantage of this new way of doing comedy.
Yes.
Where you could just take a photo and put some text to it.
And it's one of my favorite ways of calm.
That thing that I sent you the other day,
the uh,
the one of caitlyn jenner and katelyn,
is that the right way?
That's the name?
Yeah.
Caitlyn jenner in a,
uh,
a porsche and it says 2011 porsche with a rebuilt tranny hole.
And I fucking,
I laughed so hard when somebody sent genius.
I sent it to everybody I know.
I was just how like you probably have no idea who created exactly.
I felt bad in that way.
That I don't know.
And that's why I didn't post it on social media.
Yeah.
But I did retweet it.
I think.
See,
I mean his hands super cloudy.
It is cloudy,
but what was not cloudy about the fat jew situation was that he was purposely
not attributing it to the people that they created it.
And even sometimes there's some of the other ones.
That girl that was changing words changing like someone had originally tweeted
something about a cat and she would change it to a dog,
but the exact same exact same joke changed and that was the other thing fat jew
is doing is changing the text of the image but writing the same thing.
So it was deliberate like there was still doing it to.
Is he really.
There was a nice article written the other day how he's still doing it and he's.
He also has like all these fake accounts they used at giving the a credit,
but it's like a locked account with one post.
Yeah.
There's a,
there's some fuckery of foot.
It's honestly.
And even though those things are so enjoyable,
I intentionally avoided those pages on instagram just because of that reason.
Really.
Yeah.
I mean it's like I might get a laugh out of it,
but it's not.
It's not somebodies so many creative.
Like I'm not buying anything from fat jew right now.
The problem is,
yeah,
I know,
but see the thing is that your behavior influences what gets rebroadcast,
especially on instagram because if it's like previous photos you've liked and
then in other people's discover page,
I'm sure you have a lot of followers now they're seeing that thing surface so
it's hard to actually do shit on instagram without helping the shit that you're
looking at it and advertisers don't give a fuck.
They'll give him a shit load of money just because of all this stolen work.
Yeah,
but hold on a second.
So if you like something.
Yeah,
but I don't like anything.
Sometimes it's like if you go on the discover page and it'll be based on stuff
you've liked based on people you follow,
putting a picture of you up there right now based on people you follow and I
think there's one other one based on other photos you've liked,
something like that.
It,
it's,
it's algorithmically trying to make suggestions for photos that you might
actually like.
That's why it's the discover page.
So if.
Yeah,
if you don't hit the heart,
I don't know if there's a way to hit that heart.
You never hit the heart and fuck with by mistake.
Nope.
You've never hit the hard hit it
too late.
Too late.
They got the data.
I'll comment on friend's stuff,
but I don't really like things.
What's this about?
Should I.
Well,
I just feel like you can reciprocate a little something every so often.
If I saw,
if I,
if I saw joe rogan heart,
I might get a smile for a minute,
you know?
I didn't know.
Okay.
I'll start heart in your stuff.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Apparently you haven't been noticing my heart's well.
That's a thing too,
right?
Like I actually had put something up and gets hearted.
You know,
you notice how many likes you have,
but what you don't know is how many views something's got on instagram.
Yeah.
On twitter you do.
The analytics are pretty cool.
They're pretty interesting to see everything.
Yeah.
I just got one,
like the nick diaz is one that I put 407,942 views.
Look at you.
That's awesome everybody,
everybody's looking for you to make you know,
to say something about that nick diaz thing.
Yeah,
I think that'd be stoned.
Well,
here's the thing there that those people weren't even willing to take into
consideration.
The fact that he passed two tests.
He passed two tests to water tests,
world anti doping association test and failed one from some fucking local lab
and the local labs numbers were off the chart,
so two out of three tests he passed.
They weren't even willing to take into consideration those other tests because
they didn't perform them.
Not only that,
they're performing urine tests which are significantly less accurate than blood
tests,
so they fucked him.
They fucked out of $165,000 and five years of his career,
five years,
and then John Jones only got one year for cocaine.
He didn't get one year for cocaine.
Anderson silva got one year for the first steroids.
Jon jones has
not applied for a license to fight and his court case has not been settled.
He's not been found guilty,
so they don't know.
And his cocaine use was what's called out of competition cocaine use.
Like when jon jones got caught for cocaine,
he got caught for cocaine when he was not.
It wasn't going to be affecting him while he was fighting.
The idea with these tests,
with marijuana is that if you can catch someone who was taking marijuana while
they were competing,
then it could be a factor because it may affect their performance.
Yes,
it may affect their performance.
But here's the deal.
There's no scientific evidence whatsoever that marijuana is a significant effect
or performance to the point where it should be banned.
Like caffeine significantly affects performance and it's illegal.
I believe you can have up to 200 milligrams of caffeine and compete under
olympic rules.
And chael sonnen,
he actually told me that he takes it in pill form because he doesn't want to
fuck up and get an extra strong cup of coffee and break the grid or a past break
the test.
But if you like go to starbucks,
like you know,
we've,
we've tried to figure it out before,
like how much caffeine is in one of those things that brian drinks because he
drinks those 30 hours fucking the jug star of death,
you know,
but you don't really know.
Exactly.
So you have to take like a pill in order to really modulate it perfectly.
If you're an athlete.
When I was,
there was a significant effect.
Caffeine can give you more endurance.
We can help hundred percent.
I'll take caffeine before I play hockey every time.
Yeah.
And it's legal.
It's totally legal.
So I mean the arguable effect that marijuana does give you,
it might give you some dilation of your lungs and might give you a slight
advantage in your cardio because of that.
Or a focus advantage,
which is like for some people could help like a guy like nick diaz,
it might help him be more comfortable because he likes being high all the time
anyway.
So if you let him fight high,
yeah,
but it's not enough where it's gonna allow them to hurt somebody more.
See,
the idea of a performance enhancing drug is steroids,
eep,
oh,
all the stuff that like those cyclists get banned for those things make you
stronger,
faster,
and in the case of mixed martial arts,
it will allow you to hurt your opponent.
It's arguable that marijuana does have some performance enhancing effect,
like with jujitsu.
A lot of jujitsu guys,
me included,
liked to get high before they train,
but man,
I'm not much better.
I mean,
I think it's a slight thing where your leg a little better,
but it's not like with pool,
same thing.
You'll feel a little more in tune with it,
but it's not significant enough where you wouldn't be able to perform at that
level without it.
Like when we see athletes that get off steroids,
man,
the fucking drop off his god damn dramatic.
The difference between a steroid using athlete,
an athlete that's forced to go off steroids,
you see it in their body,
they get soft,
they see they have loose skin.
You see it in their physical performance,
they get tired quicker.
They're not as aggressive,
they're not as confident.
They start posting shit on their instagram.
Praise all this motivational shit like a suicidal stripper.
That's what happens,
man.
It starts with fuck with your head because you realize like you,
you got to pump yourself up because you're not jack to the tits on some
artificial testosterone.
Right?
So that in comparison to pot,
there's no fucking comparison.
Right?
And testosterone was legal until like a year ago.
There were allowing these guys to get on testosterone replacement therapy is pot
legal in other sports while the nba is apparently the one sport where so many
guys are smoking pot playing.
That's what I.
That they don't have it in the contract where they test them,
they don't,
they don't allow themselves to be tested.
So how is it that this is even on the table to be,
you know,
first of all,
because there's no union there.
If there was a fighters' union,
fighters' union could go to the athletic kind of,
fuck you,
we're not coming to vegas,
you dummies.
And then the other problem is if someone's band in vegas,
they're band in the world because of you violated and there's all sorts of
fucking loss.
Who bullshit part that I can't wrap my head around.
Not only that,
but you're being banned by idiots.
Okay?
You're being banned by people who don't understand the sport.
If they did understand a sport,
first of all,
they would have fired 60 percent of their judges,
60 percent of their judges,
any judge that hasn't have any martial arts experience,
a judge it,
you should run them through a course load.
Is this guy in danger?
Is he in danger?
Now?
Is this dangerous?
Is this submission close?
Is this one close?
How?
How effective is that?
If you don't know that you can't judge a martial arts fight on a,
on a professional level,
but yet they do,
so these are ineffective commissions in the first place.
On top of that,
they're bureaucrats.
These are government people and firing these people.
It's just like firing someone from the dmv or firing some from the post office.
It's fucking difficult and there's all sorts of hoops and latin.
There's protections that those people have in place that the fighters do not
have.
So you have an unfair playing field and these people have this ultimate tyranny
over fighters.
So it seems pretty obvious that Nevada is fucked,
fucked.
Is there any chance that the ufc affiliation with Nevada ever changes?
Well,
they can't have fights in Nevada.
Nevada's the spot,
man.
If you want to have fights,
you go to vegas.
I know.
Why does it have?
Why?
Because it's the shit.
It's the best place to funding.
But how much could they continue to fuck up and you still continue to do it.
They need to be overhauled.
Not vegas.
Vegas is fucking awesome.
Look if you're going to have fights,
but I'm saying I've been tied to the mgm.
I've been there and fucking casinos there until 6:00 in the morning if you want.
I completely agree.
But anytime you're in any kind of negotiation,
you have to be willing to walk away and if they continue to fuck up,
what's the risk to them?
I think the public reaction to this and its thing is unprecedented.
I tweeted the phone number for the Nevada state of audition today and say,
please call them up and let them know how you feel about them fucking over nick
diaz.
I'm retweeted.
You see they can't even fucking take calls now.
They're just swamped and um,
I'll do it tomorrow too.
Yeah,
I'll do it until they stop.
I'll do it for the rest of my life.
I'll fucking wake up every morning.
I have an alarm clock.
Well,
here's the new number for the scheduled tweets that they stole five years from
this guy's career and they stole $165,000 from his person and they weren't even
willing to take into consideration the other two tests that he failed.
It is a goddamn dog and pony show.
It's a tyranny.
And what these people are doing is wrong.
It's just wrong because it's not a person who set out to cheat.
This is the guy who doesn't use steroids.
Nick diaz is notoriously anti steroids.
This is a guy who was one of the toughest,
most exciting guys in the sport.
He's fun to watch and also probably has social anxiety issues that marijuana
helps alleviate.
Yeah,
I've read that.
I read that interview with him like about what he said shortly after.
Yeah,
it's awful,
man.
You know,
look what they did is wrong.
It's wrong.
It gets not.
You shouldn't fight high.
Okay.
If you fight,
hi,
there should be a penalty.
Like 50 bucks
for it.
Listen man,
if a guy kicks your ass high,
he'd probably kick your ass sober.
You know,
I just don't.
I don't.
It's not like taking beta blockers or something to completely eliminate your
nervousness.
Yeah.
That's the thing.
That's the one thing I heard though,
is that maybe your pain threshold is elevated.
You know what,
man,
I don't buy that.
Here's why I don't buy that.
You don't feel pain when you're fighting anyway.
You're so jacked up with adrenaline.
There's so many times when you fight and after it's over,
you realize your hand is broken or there's something wrong with you.
Like jon jones,
perfect example.
I'm interviewing him while I'm interviewing.
After you beat the shit out shell son and he looks down and sees his toe,
he had no idea.
He had no idea until he looked down.
He saw there's toe was flipped over and the bottom of his toes facing I was
there.
I saw it happen and he immediately was,
oh my toe.
Oh man.
We got him a chair and he sat down and I continue the interview with him.
Go literally going into shock over his toe.
Why was that?
It wasn't because he was on a drug.
He wasn't high.
It was because it was his adrenaline.
Would that injury have had to have the fight stopped if a date,
most likely,
if it went to the end of the round or whatever.
Ryan hall had a similar injury.
It wasn't to his big toe,
but it's one of his other toes was a compound fracture was broken and the bone
was poking out of his toe and he still fought two more rounds with it and he
still threw kicks with that fucking leg and won the fight.
That's how tough uriah hall.
But I mean,
he had to,
you know,
he had to be mentally tough.
I mean,
he had to go back to his corner.
He realized his toe is completely fucked and he just said,
okay,
whatever.
And I mean limped back to his corner.
But once the round started,
dude was on his feet and moving around like nothing was wrong.
He just dealt with the pain and said,
I'm going to win this fucking fight.
Anyway.
You know,
and a lot of that is also because of adrenaline.
Your adrenaline shields you from a,
you know,
your adrenaline realizes you're in a battle for your life.
You don't need to worry about bruises,
you don't need to worry about pain.
It's not pain necessarily that stops fighters.
It's debilitating techniques like a liver shot.
When you get hit with a liver shot,
it's not like,
oh my god,
it was so painful.
It fucking definitely hurts.
But the real problem with the liver shot,
as it shuts your system down,
your system doesn't work anymore.
You get nailed with like a left hook to the liver,
boom,
it hits you.
And it's this crazy feeling like your breath doesn't work anymore,
your legs lock up and you're like,
it's not a pain thing.
It's a system shut down.
When you get knocked out,
you get kicked in the head.
It's not that your.
Your head hurts,
of course it hurts,
but the real problem is not paying.
The real problem is your brain shuts off your brain.
You get net kicked,
he cuts off the circulation to your brain,
spark the other.
The fucking nerves get shattered.
Everything get walked out and your brain goes,
okay,
night,
and you shut off.
It's a full system.
Wasn't a choice at all,
honestly.
Yeah,
there's pain that these guys experience,
but that's not necessarily what stops fights.
So the pain threshold thing,
I don't buy it.
I think the real pain threshold is adrenaline.
That's what really keeps you from feeling pain.
And we're going to have that naturally.
That's the most effective thing.
Marijuana is an effective pain reducer after competition or after training.
It's with one of the things that people really like to do.
They have a hard day of training.
They like to sit back,
smoke a joint and watch a little tv.
Well,
they can't do that if they're being tested,
you know,
in this district and so on.
Yeah.
Well again,
the marijuana thing,
they've changed the threshold considerably.
And I had jeff,
no wicki on the podcast.
I listened to that episode now.
Amazing.
Really interesting guy and very smart and very,
you know,
on top of the testing thing.
And he's like,
it's out of competition if you're not,
if you're.
You would literally have to get high the day of the fight to test positive.
Now that's the way they're doing it.
So the test that diaz got popped for was before this alteration was made dope.
It's by the current standards.
So the problem is he tested twice under the threshold of the current standards.
The water tests had him under the threshold which says he was not high when he
competed,
but the tasks that they use from,
I believe it was quest labs,
sorry if I'm wrong,
but I believe which is,
you know,
a very good lab,
but it showed have completely different test than the test that water
instituted.
On top of that,
again,
we're talking about urine,
we're talking about urine versus blood and when you're testing metabolite,
so why,
why in that particular,
in this particular case,
did that test take precedent over the water there?
Test.
Who's they?
Nevada state athletic commission.
That's where it's fucked.
It's not.
The ufc is test.
The ufc has no fucking place in this.
They brought in the u.
S ada,
us anti-doping association,
which is where it novitsky comes up.
Right,
right.
Brought those guys in.
I guess I'm referring to them as they use because they're high.
They are hired by them.
They're hired by the ufc to clean up the sport,
but they have no say on how the tests are implemented,
how the results are dispersed,
what the idea of bringing in the government and bringing in a guy like novitsky
wicki is,
look,
if you really want to clean up,
clean up the sport,
you hire a fucking bulldog who's just going to go after it.
You don't do it yourself because if you do it yourself,
there's always the possibility that someone could hide the results because
there's a financial interest like you would know you would test conor mcgregor.
He finally,
he's fighting high,
like little calm.
Listen,
you're saying some great shit.
He can't fight high dude,
but with the usa da,
you don't have a say in how the stuff is.
You don't have that sounds perfect.
Exactly,
and that's how they want to do it and that's what.
That's what that show,
but I don't understand what medina understand what good it is.
If what do you wasted all this money for it because the Nevada state athletic
commission is incompetent and there they are a tyranny and they are a bunch of
people that haven't.
If you watch the fucking the commission,
those people are drunk with power.
They're drunk with power and they felt like they were making made fools of
because he's tested positive before,
but he tested positive before,
under their different thresholds.
The thresholds that existed before the current established standard.
It's all fucked.
Who hires these people like where?
It's a good question.
Like where?
Who do you,
who do you go after?
Is there some kind?
Is it the governor at the highest level?
It should be the government.
The governor.
I think the governor did step in once and there was an investigation one,
there was a woman who was.
She was.
She judged the tim bradley manny pacquiao,
fight like really poorly and she was one of the reasons why pack y'all didn't
win that fight and then they went over her,
her history of judging fights and they're like,
what the fuck?
Like she gets a lot of fights wrong and she would get fights wrong that like
we're a greeley bad decisions and so they were trying to figure out like,
what does she know about fight?
Does she know?
Anyhow,
she got this job,
hired her,
how does this work?
And so the governor stepped in because there was a national outcry over a couple
of boxing decisions and I say it,
his office needs to be bombarded right now.
I hope they are.
Well,
there's a government petition,
somebody put out a white house petition to reinstate nick diaz,
but what's what,
what's shown up,
this is what needed to be done.
Okay?
And this is the good thing about this.
We needed to see how dumb these fucking people are or I need to see how bad they
are at their jobs,
how cruel they are,
how callous they are.
The fact that they don't,
they just think it's think it's okay to take away $165,000 from the guys purse
and take away his ability to compete and make a living for five years in his
prime.
It's career just over.
Yeah,
five years is a career killer.
I mean,
nick,
how did you come up with that number?
Because they're assholes.
Did that number come just come out of.
Because I have,
I've never heard.
Maybe with the exception of.
What's his name?
The guy who the manko alexander's flamenco got tested positive in California and
andy foster,
who the chairman in California is,
he's very hell bent on taking out cheaters.
He doesn't want any of that shit.
And schlep mancos tests were through the roof.
His testosterone was playing stairway.
Yeah.
And uh,
they,
you know,
and he's got a court case and I don't know how that's going to go.
I don't know what really.
We don't know.
You never know.
How do you feel about.
Okay.
Even in the case of steroids where it's an obvious performance enhancer,
how do you feel about a five year suspension for that?
Like a five year suspension?
Is that,
is there ever a place for five years?
Well,
here's the thing.
Devonna tried to ban vandelay silva for a lifetime.
That was what I was thinking of.
Yeah,
that's who I was last.
That they lost that in court.
They could so they couldn't.
They went to court.
Vandelays lawyers went to court and they beat that.
Of course they beat him because he didn't live in test positive for anything.
Ran away from the test.
You ran away from the tests that you run away from the test.
In their eyes,
you're guilty and they wanted to send a message.
They're not to be trifled with says,
d is going to take this to court.
You think,
fuck yeah,
and he's going to win too.
And I hope he sues the shit out of them.
I hope he soon as the shit out of him.
I really do and I hope he wins and I hope that the governor steps in or someone
steps in because my say you,
there are people that you can hire that will understand what the fuck is going
on.
You need former athletes.
You need people who are experts in science and medicine that understand what the
thresholds are.
Understand the difference between urine tests and blood tests if you and also
you need commissioners that you.
You're,
you're gonna need people that are,
that have the educated ability to make these judgements based on whatever
discipline that they would need to be a master of.
To understand this,
like if you're talking about steroids,
you would need someone who's a steroid expert if you're talking about
performance enhancing drugs like meth or you would need someone.
You should have to establish the fact that you understand what the effects of
all these things are.
You shouldn't have to have some education and the effects of all these things.
Now with marijuana,
there's.
There's no data you've just got.
You've got no data that shows that if a person takes marijuana,
they can hurt someone more easily than if they don't take marijuana.
So as soon as you have that,
you don't have any data,
so if you don't have any data then you've got to go.
How you banning people for this.
Like ronda rousey fucking went off today.
It was watched.
I watched that clip.
She went off and drop the mic after it was over and one of the things that she
said I totally agree with about marijuana.
She said this in the past too,
it's an invasion of privacy is what it is.
You're invading someone's privacy.
Just like the fact that if you're.
If you work for a company and the company decides to test you and you work all
week,
you do a great job,
you work hard,
and then fridays,
since 5:00 baby,
it's over.
You want to smoke a joint,
your home,
you worked all day.
You want to watch the walking dead.
You want to put your feet up and you want to get high.
You can't.
You fucking can because they own you.
They own you.
They own your flesh.
They literally own your mind when you're not there because everyone knows that
marijuana is not psychoactive permanently.
It's not like you smoke a joint on friday and then you show up on monday
morning.
You're still high as fuck and you're high for the rest of your life.
That's not the case.
So if you,
if you,
if you smoke pot,
you will be tested four or five weeks from now,
you will still test positive.
If you don't smoke any pot,
if you get high right now and then four weeks from now they give you a
urinalysis test,
depending on what they're looking for.
If they're just trying to trace metabolites,
you can still test positive and four weeks,
that's fucking insane.
So it is.
It's simply a control thing.
It's a power thing.
These people or government people or government people that like to be able to
tell people what to do.
That's my concern though,
is if it's a power thing,
how deep is it?
How many levels does it go to?
How many judges are friends would not admit should find out.
Yeah,
well they probably already on the case,
but ultimately I hope they're on the case.
Ultimately autonomous catholic public outcry.
Look,
this is a tyranny.
These are a few people that are deciding which again,
we're not talking about steroids here,
we're just talking about pot.
Yeah,
it just doesn't make sense.
And we're also talking about a guy who passed to world anti doping agency tests.
Those are the most trick fucking tests in the world of sports.
He passed two of those and failed a quest.
I think quest,
again,
I apologize from wrong,
but the bottom line is the tests were not the test that you need when you're
taking away a guy's fucking livelihood and you're finding him for $165,000 out
of a $500,000 purse,
which by the way,
he has to pay his managers.
He has to pay taxes.
He has to be all these different things.
When you make 500 grand,
you don't make 500 grand because you have a manager,
the manager has 10 percent.
You might have an agent and the agent gets a piece.
You might have a lawyer,
you might have a business manager,
you might have.
You have to pay taxes.
You have training,
expensive training partners.
You mean you have to be very strict and nick is notoriously disciplined with his
diet.
I mean he's.
He eats all organic food.
He's mostly vegan,
except I think he eats some fish.
He doesn't need any land animals and he does this based on the effect on his
body because he's an extreme endurance athlete.
He does a lot of triathlons and he does a lot of running.
He swam back and forth from alcatraz twice.
I mean he's a motherfucker dude.
He takes care of his body and if he's smoking pot,
that should tell you the pot's not bad for your body.
It's real simple,
but he's not cheating.
He's not doing steroids.
He's not doing anything that gives them an unfair advantage.
He's working hard.
He's tough as shit.
Any fucking fight smart and these assholes.
They stole his ability to entertain and he's one of the most popular guys in the
fucking sport.
When he came back and fought anderson silva,
the paper view was through the roof.
And why was that?
Well,
partly because when people want to see what anderson silva would look like after
he came back from a leg injury,
this horrific leg break,
but also it's because he's fighting nick diaz,
nick diaz,
gonna talk shit to him.
Like he did,
like he got in his face.
He's like,
what bitch?
What bitch?
Like nobody ever done that to anderson silva before he laid down on the ground
like he was making a sleepy face like,
look,
I'm sleep and you're boring the fuck out of me,
and jumped back up to his feet.
He humiliated anderson completely fucked with his head inside that cage.
That's what people paid for and what he is experiencing right now is a bunch of
assholes taken away his ability to compete,
taken away his ability to thrill people at what he does best has worked for more
than a fucking decade as a professional mixed martial arts fighter.
More than a dad who knows how many years before that training and learning how
to fight all that's taken away by some assholes.
I don't think it's going to stick it all.
It's not going to stick to.
I hope the the what the outcome is,
is that we realized that these people are just bad at what they do and they get
removed.
Kevin,
I only wrote a fantastic piece about it.
I'm kevin.
I who's a very respected sports reporter.
I forget what,
what publication he writes for,
but he's very respected in the world of combat sports especially.
He said they expose themselves as being ridiculous.
They expose themselves being incompetent.
Yeah.
It's like a.
It's like it takes a critical moment like this to get everybody motivated enough
to actually incite some change.
It's.
It made me so angry,
dude.
Yeah.
I haven't seen.
I haven't seen this kind of reaction.
Not that I can remember since the lion killer.
Yeah.
This is like the,
you know,
the other side of the thing,
because it's.
This is a.
Most people would taking social media,
but the way that joe is talking about here is,
is,
is measured,
right?
He's not saying go to these people's homes and torture their children.
Right.
That's the problem is that like this stuff gets misconstrued.
Like getting back to the lion killer thing is like,
yes,
be motivated,
but be smart about it.
Yes.
Well,
it's also the thing that we were talking about before.
It's.
I think you're right though.
It does bring it full circle.
It's like this highlights what's good about being able to express themselves
and it also highlights how these established sort of structures they operate on
this old paradigm and they haven't caught up to the new paradigm yet.
They don't understand that this is not going to end like this whole nick diaz
thing and the vandelay silva thing.
You've got to legends of the sport that you've fucked.
You fucked over,
you know,
and there's one thing also when people are injured and they're taking things to
help them recover.
Man,
I'm not against that.
I'm just not.
Oh really?
Yeah.
If a guy,
like there's certain things,
there's certain things that you can take that will help you recover from injury
that are absolutely illegal.
Like,
here's one stem cells.
Okay,
here's one that I have personal experience.
Are those uh,
outlawed yet?
No,
they're not.
But dude,
they fucking work.
They weren't to repair injuries.
They're incredible.
I mean,
it's incredible.
The,
they can regenerate cartilage now.
So if you don't have access to stem cells and you're competing with someone who
does and this guy gets a stem cell injection on his knees and his knees are
fixed up,
so he's going to be able to train harder and you have to tough through it.
Well what should that be?
Legal or there's a similarity to that to people who get knee injuries or knee
surgeries and then take a steroid to help themselves repair,
repair quicker so they can get back to competing quicker.
You know,
one of the fucked up things about this too is just looking at it surface level.
The these,
these dudes go out there and beat each other up for other people's
entertainment.
And you know,
in that interview with diaz after the fact,
he was talking about how the people making decisions about what he can and can't
do.
Those people sitting on the board or whatever the hell it is,
they don't have to experience that.
You know what I mean?
Like they're not in what you're saying as far as recovery is concerned.
It's like how can a regular person make a judgment on that?
And coming back to the thing about having a union fighters are the only people
who should be making decisions about fighters,
right?
Like most fighters feel very strongly that you shouldn't be able to use
performance enhancing drugs and compete.
And rhonda has said this very clearly.
Um,
and she,
she says something I totally agree with the difference between this and any
other sport is if you give a guy steroids and he plays baseball,
what's the big deal?
He's just going to hit a ball better.
But if you give a guy steroids and you let them fight,
he could administer damage that maybe he would not have been able to administer.
He could hurt someone that maybe he wouldn't have had the endurance to her.
He wouldn't have been able to deliver the combination that wound up hurting this
person very badly.
Or possibly even killing someone.
And she said that if someone ever does die and the other person tests positive
for steroids,
they should,
they should really get charged with murder.
Well,
yeah,
but I mean why it kind of does.
Right?
I don't know about that.
I don't know about that either.
But there's a fine line and I just think,
I just think it's so hard to put yourself in the person's shoes that's
competing.
Like for me,
for me,
I don't have somebody
trying to knock my fucking head off and if that was going to work for me,
I just feel like that you need different kind of set of rules agreed upon by the
person you're about to step in there with.
That's an interesting way of looking at it.
And I agree with that as well.
Like say if you guys were going to fight and you made an agreement that we're
both going to be juicy juice.
Yes.
You should be able to do that.
Yeah,
I think I agree with that.
And we.
And we could write.
Yeah.
No,
it's not legal.
Well,
not in.
Not,
not.
Not on a page.
Not in the United States.
The island though.
The next thing for fucking buy an island.
No,
I didn't know what was it?
That podcast with the floating countries.
So.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
These guys are want to be a barge off the coast.
What do they call that shit again?
Seasteading seasteading.
Thank you.
That's what it was.
That's,
that's.
That's totally true.
They need to have seasteading fights just off the coast of catalina and fucking
they duke it out.
All juiced up.
Everybody's 190 fucking percent testosterone free hookers in the audience.
Sounds exciting.
Show how much you paid and get in there.
That wasn't ours.
A ticket.
That's a.
Well,
that's not enough.
These hookers are good.
That's not enough money to pay for the ticket.
If they're all free,
how much these girls going to get paid?
They just want to be on the island.
This agree,
but I think in bringing it full circle,
what we're exposing here is that this ability to communicate about things,
it's changing.
It's changing radically than anybody has a say.
Now,
like literally anybody,
no matter you're not vetted out based on your intelligence,
you're not judged beforehand,
you're not screened is anybody can just scream out.
Like,
I have a friend who goes and reads comments on his stuff and he gets all upset.
I go,
you're getting upset at people you don't even know.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You were allowing these people into your head and like they're saying,
these people say idiotic things and he gets upset.
I'm like,
of course they're gonna.
Say idiotic things.
They're idiots.
Do you hang out with idiots?
Will listen,
man.
If you go to idiots houses and start asking them questions,
we're going to say some shit you disagree with or you gonna argue with them all
day.
You won't have a life.
You don't have enough time in the day to pay attention.
Look at yourself,
make your own job.
He'd be honest and be self objective.
Make your own sort of analysis of the pros and cons of your behavior and your
thinking,
and then if they disagree with that,
you kind of have at least some sort of an idea,
but you don't.
You don't have that idea on the internet.
See,
because you just,
you all you see is text.
You don't see the person's life behind that text.
You don't see what a fuck up they've been their whole life.
That's allowed them to be lacking context.
You don't see that they're 12
fucking,
you know.
That's another thing to take into consideration.
Wonder like what the effect of it,
if like let's say for example,
I had access to the same stuff when I was 12.
What?
I have been the same asshole probably I think I would,
I was an angry kid if I,
if I was um,
if I was able to for whatever reason get upset about something that I felt like
it's somewhere that it would be justified.
But again,
my anger wouldn't have really been directed towards what I was getting upset
about.
They would have just given me the green light to express some of the anger that
I had about my own life.
You know,
that's.
I think that's a lot of what we're dealing with you.
I think it just a manifests itself in these various causes,
you know,
like days that you,
like you said before it is that people are not all that happy about their own
personal situation,
but it's a lot easier to latch on to conflict that someone has sort
of shaped for you than it is to necessarily tackle the super personal thing that
you're upset with.
Yeah.
Or get your life to a point of balance where you can actually look at anything
that's going on in the world and have just sort of an intelligent well,
and,
and that's.
And that's where I,
I think that even though this is the wild west and everyone has a voice,
there are obviously voices that have emerged as more prominent when communities
to communities and I think that that's where I still see a sense of
responsibility that k fine all you need is a smartphone in twitter to,
to say what you want but there,
but it's not.
The influence still exists.
Yes.
And I feel like sometimes you'll witness influence being irresponsible.
Um,
case in point.
And I mean,
I don't know how people feel about this,
but like when jimmy kimmel was crying on the air,
like for me that's an abusive influence because he wasn't painting the entire
picture.
There he was,
he was picking his side in a,
in a very short form.
Little what was it,
two sentences and then showing that kind of a physical emotion associated with
it.
That was fuel,
man.
Yeah.
Well that was his perspective though.
He's got a limited perspective.
First of all,
you saw his perspective about video games and how offended people got about
that.
They were calling in death threats against him,
which I found incredibly ironic after he defends the lion hunter.
Then he goes off about video games sport like fuck you.
I'm just saying.
I'm sure.
I'm just saying I agree with the video game guys.
It's a sport.
Yeah.
I'm with.
So he's what he was doing by saying what by by mocking it.
I guess he's trying to do comedy,
but yeah,
he's being disrespectful to an emerging sport,
which is an unquestionably involves skill and intelligent planning and strategy
and just didn't know.
He didn't come.
It was also not informed about the line guy.
He was wrong.
That's what I'm saying.
It's like I think we all need to get smarter if we have established a voice on
the web,
like take an extra second to before you hit that send button.
I know I've.
I've had this experience myself in,
in,
in the various communications I've had about products let's say,
or videos I want to make or tweets I want to send of like what is the effect of
this thing going to be.
It might even be the way that I feel and I still don't want to do it because I
don't.
I'm thinking about the reaction.
I'm thinking about the trickle effect of this particular sentiment and I don't
think we're there yet.
I think a lot of the influencers,
if you want to call them that are behaving irresponsibly in,
in wa,
in wanting to put out a hot take,
wanting to have something to say about this topic that has overwhelmed the web
that we're susceptible to the same thing that the lower level jerk in his room
or that other guy that you were speaking about because it's attractive,
it's attractive to get involved in the conversation.
Even with limited information.
That's a real.
You're
right,
you're dead right,
and I think we've all been guilty of that and I think that's a really good point
and a really important point because I think that whenever a subject comes up
people do.
If say there was no podcast,
no podcasts at all,
and someone brought up some point like that lady who's denying people gay
marriage,
that lady in Kentucky and we will be like this fucking dumb cunt.
Like we,
we'll,
we'll all start talking shit like someone,
someone should go over house to hold her down and make make guys fuck right in
front of her face.
A bunch of crazy shit that's not really a responsible thing to say,
but then you do it in a podcast like this.
One of the things that I like about people wearing headsets is that at least it
makes you think that you're do something professionally.
Ah,
there's a bit of a ride.
It's been a few times where I was like,
man,
maybe wearing headsets like,
because you forget that.
That is really cool what you're saying.
Yeah.
I never thought of that.
That's how I think about it because I think there's something,
something about it being in your ear,
like I hear you in my ear just as clearly as I hear him,
even though he's a few extra feet away,
every.
We're all in the same sound waves and I and that makes me feel professional
extracts you just enough from the sort of regular hangout zone that you're like,
okay,
people are listening.
Yeah.
People do.
You measure it just to maybe a second.
Wait a second longer.
It's a real point that I think a lot of people,
especially comedians when I have comedians on the podcast,
sometimes they just forget that or they're not aware of that or they're not
aware of it to the extent that I am because I know the numbers like you're.
You're doing a show and there's a lot of people listening and you have a
responsibility to be entertaining,
but you also have responsibility to be accurate.
You can't really say things that people might just take as fact.
You haven't researched them because you,
you.
You're reaching millions and millions of people now and I can change the way
they look at things.
Yep.
So like when this mike huckabee guy latches on,
you know that fucking guy who latched onto that kim lady,
what the fuck her name is?
The Kentucky clerk wouldn't allow it,
gave me.
He fucking immediately like,
this is a great thing of who he starts tweeting about it.
There's a warm religious freedom,
religious liberty,
and it was hilarious.
Like hashtag religious liberty and all these other apes got involved.
They're all
screaming and yelling and it's cool.
It's cool to watch because you're watching like the last gasps of a dying,
ignorant perspective.
You're literally seeing the last few generations of monkeys that believe some
dumb shit that was written on animal skins thousands of years ago.
You're seeing the last echoes of the game of telephone where you tell someone,
and I tell someone and it gets translated from generation to generation for over
a thousand years before anybody buys.
It bothers writing it down.
Then once they write it down,
they write it down into fucking dead language and that's to be translated to all
these other languages.
I mean,
that is what we're seeing.
We see that lady screaming with her glasses on the mike huckabee fucking
convention,
going to stop all that.
Fuck fucking she's yelling it out.
We're seeing a woman who contradicts the very message of the bible itself
because she's been married for fucking dimes.
You're not supposed to get divorced.
How many religious people that you know that have tattoos?
You're not supposed to get tattoos.
He can't fucking pick and choose.
We can't pick and choose your shit.
Cherry picker religion.
They do.
They cherry pick what they like and what they don't like about their religion
she has done is just as bad as a mouth fucking.
I think what I think.
I think what you're saying is completely true here in north America,
but globally religion.
Oh yeah,
it ain't.
He's slowing down will.
It's hard to get the internet to like places in the middle of nowhere and it's
hard to get the influence of those communities in them,
but it will happen eventually.
I agree,
and when it does happen,
you realize that your perspective is simply the perspective of the people around
you,
that you have sort of adopted and your,
your view of life,
your view of religion,
your view of all.
I mean I've had people on my podcast that used to be muslim and they've become
atheists and they,
they've.
They lived there in,
in,
in the middle east and they were a part of that culture and they thought like
those people did and then they came over here and they started reading.
I started getting into it.
They hard to really know what the fuck is.
This ideology that I've subscribed to,
this isn't the only way to think and not only that,
it's not if you take enough time and look at it objectively,
it's not even rational.
It's not like this is a bulletproof ideology,
but that's how it's most religions try to pass their stuff off.
Scientology tries to pass them their self off like that.
They try to pass their stuff off as bulletproof,
like this is the way that's the sale,
that's the sales pitch.
This is the way to become happy.
Yeah.
But again,
I think the internet is the cure to that information.
Information for sure.
Is it.
Is is the number one sort of ulterior fighting force against this type of stuff
that you're talking about?
Access to it in the same way we were talking about getting internet into a hard
to reach places.
That's actually a google x project that they're working on with these air
balloons.
I don't know if you've heard about this.
Yeah,
the wifi balloons,
right,
so it's like crazy weather balloons that hover above areas that have no service.
I'm hard to reach places and they're on a cycle,
so your phone is rapidly switching between the one that's actually overhead at
that point and is that one slowly drifts out of range on the jet stream.
The next one float off the next one,
flow,
flow is in,
and then you hand off to that one so you don't notice an interruption in
connection.
But since a weather balloon can't sit there forever,
it,
you know,
it's,
it's float floating along along with the weather system.
Uh,
but some really cool technology.
There's some videos online that show how they've made it a.
So the idea being,
it's like places like North Korea for float,
you
fucking balloons to just shoot them out of the sky.
Well,
it's actually kind of,
they're,
they're pretty high up sound like you're selling them.
And I am,
I am because fuck this North Korea shit for real,
for real,
for real.
That's bonkers that we're allowing that to still exist.
And,
and the beauty of it,
it's like going in there without weapons going in there with information.
Don't you love that storyline?
We're going in there with connectivity.
Bitch.
We're gonna.
We're gonna,
we're gonna.
We're gonna.
Bring it up from the grassroots,
the rise of a nation led bulbs.
Let the people make the decision for themselves.
And you've got South Korea right there.
I mean,
it'd be so easy.
So you get this beautiful little base to let these things go over.
I've just,
I love the idea of informational warfare.
You know,
that he doesn't,
that he doesn't have to be about bullets and bombs,
that if you can reach enough people with a particular message,
you know,
they can figure it out just to just like,
right for them.
It'll take a lot of time.
They're so deep in the web.
I don't know man,
because anywhere like you just spoke about a person completely changing their
religious outlook just upon arriving somewhere else.
When you think about it,
what is the difference?
It's the information available to them even though it might not be on a phone or
or a or a laptop.
It's the information they're supposed to by the culture they're surrounded with.
It's not the geographic location.
Yeah,
you're exactly right.
And if you look at how quickly uprisings took place in places like Egypt and so
on spring,
it was just like give them twitter,
holy shit.
And immediate overhaul in the behavior because all of a sudden now you've got
this massive cultural shift of communication and so on,
and people with access to google.
I mean,
why do you think China has been blocking youtube and google since day one,
day one,
because the warfare is,
has always been about information.
World war two doesn't happen without propaganda.
Will have a friend who works at worked,
doesn't work anymore.
Google.
But she would go over to China and have meetings with these people and they were
like,
well,
we want access to these people's emails.
We want to be able to block these things.
They're like,
whoa,
whoa.
That's not what we're dealing with.
That's an important distinction to make because it's not that.
It's not that I'm,
that they're just blocked.
It's also that google doesn't want to be there either for those exact reasons.
So it's a,
it's a,
it's a two way thing.
But,
uh,
I think,
I think that the control control structures that exist in our global
perspective,
they exist for because of an agenda,
a particular agenda,
whatever that might be.
And you can't control people if you,
if you can,
if you don't control information flow.
And also I think that people are almost automatically or naturally gravitate
towards controlling others if they have power,
Nevada,
Nevada state athletic commission or any king or dictatorship or what people felt
about the nsa.
That's why people are so outraged with edward stoten thing that these people who
are no different than,
you know,
different than I just got jobs and could research ex-girlfriends emails and I
mean they could do all kinds of creepy shit that you shouldn't really be able to
do in the public.
Didn't know about power corrupts.
Power corrupts absolutely.
Absolutely pal.
Absolute.
Whatever the hell it works.
How's it going?
Absolute power corrupts absolute power corrupts absolutely.
And absolute power corrupts absolutely.
That's what it is.
Power corrupts and absolute power corrupts absolutely.
Yeah.
And the governments have absolute power.
Government of North Korea absolutely has absolute power and that's the scariest
version that we have.
And it's also throws in the face whenever the us talks about invading Syria or
in these other places.
Like what about the worst spot?
The spot with nuclear bombs,
it's run by a fucking nut,
completely true.
And when you have allies like South Korea,
Japan that are right in the zone,
they're writing bombs zone and like what?
I just imagined that there was a border here with that kind of shit on the other
side.
Like that's a,
a daily life type situation for people in South Korea.
It's a completely developed place,
much like here culturally complete free and open marketplace and their neighbor,
their neighbor or these psychos,
like it's one thing for us to think about it at this distance,
but those people daily life is wondering what the fuck is gonna happen and the
whole country,
north and South Korea is like the size of Texas that too had those big as North
Korea and South Korea.
Find that out.
I would say that combine.
No,
I would say you're about right.
And if their grocery stores are fake,
you know,
and if they're like putting this whole fake thing on their nuclear stories
affect,
you know,
like how they have the vice documentary.
Yeah,
the restaurants.
Yeah.
Vice did they set up fake restaurants for pr purposes to make it look like
they're normal,
but you know,
you got another.
Their nuclear plans probably fake.
They can't do anything.
They're just,
you know,
they've actually proven that,
that they're nuclear missiles and they're all wonky.
They've done so they saw canadians or something.
Now I'm not going to look at him.
I'm not going to get killed.
Hey,
we keep you guys honest.
All right.
That's our job.
While you're nicer than us,
we always go over there and go,
god,
why can't we be like canadian firm that can settle a liquor guy heard?
I've actually been getting a.
Yeah,
that's fucked up.
Don't get me started on that.
What's going on?
The government.
What government owns all the candidate?
Cbo,
provincial.
The lcpo fuck you.
All right.
Now you guys don't have legal weed anywhere.
Do you?
Legal weed?
Yeah.
Well medical like.
Yeah,
but no,
Colorado.
Nobody has given a fuck about weeding Canada for as long as I've been alive.
So it.
Maybe it's not on paper,
just make it on paper.
You know,
Colorado has made more money in taxes this year for the first time ever.
Then alcohol with weed.
Oh,
your money from.
We'd actually.
And this is,
that's perfect for what he's talking about.
The lcpo is the ontario liquor board.
Who is the single biggest retailer of alcohol in the world.
That's hilarious.
Because it's a huge marketplace.
Well big a big marketplace.
And they're the only sellers so they get to set the price.
So alcohol is expensive.
The stores are fucking magnificent samples and when they close at 8:00 PM.
So if you want to get some Jack Daniels at eight,
10 years,
you know,
most of them are 10.
Well,
it still,
he doesn't even go to bed until six or 10 and listen and listen,
there's an argument to be made.
I,
you know,
I see that side of it,
but there's some shady ass liquor stores too that you don't have to deal with
because it's,
it's treated the way that it is.
But see that's part of the fun of an open market.
Those shady ass lickers.
That's true.
In phoenix.
Went to a drive through store.
We're in phoenix.
There was a guy who,
uh,
he's dead now so we can talk shit about him.
He used to run this comedy club and he was out of his fucking mind.
He wouldn't let us drink on stage.
He said it was a law and we found out that there wasn't a law.
So what we decided to do was drive to this drive through fucking liquor store on
a bottle of Jack Daniels in a flask.
And then while I was on stage,
I explained that I was drinking diet coke,
but I liked to have warm diet coke and my cold.
Makes sense.
You would like turn around,
pull out of my pocket and one of the waitresses ratted me out.
Yeah,
I'm with you either tomorrow by the way.
Oh,
phoenix Arizona.
A stand up live.
Unless the shooter hits me and I go to naca.
The phoenix shooter?
Yeah.
There's a highway shooter that's just shooting cars on in phoenix.
I think he's got 11 people so far killed.
Uh,
no,
no one had been killed yet,
but he's just shooting with sniper rifles.
And hinchcliffe and ico to naca.
That's a great show.
And that's that standup live.
Great fucking comedy club.
We got to.
Unfortunately,
we've got to wrap this thing up.
I go.
Can I just be clear about one thing here?
Open market booze in ontario.
I'm for that.
Okay.
The lcb ozone is okay,
but I'm not.
That sounds like I was on team lcpo there.
I see what else cbo is.
That's the ontario liquor board.
The group that controls alcohol.
Okay.
Free market.
Yes.
Yeah.
It didn't sound like you were.
Okay.
Well it was painting something.
Let's get frustrated every time I go to toronto and then I get some Jack
Daniels.
I'll wait.
I can plan in advance.
Yeah.
Now I just forget what.
You could still go to a bar.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
But I'm,
you know,
I think liquor stores should be 24 hours a day.
That's the one thing that I really love about vegas is that they don't restrict
when you drink.
The bad thing is you have to have 15 different kinds of aids to get a medical
marijuana card there,
but that's just for now.
Yeah,
well what I suppose to thinking there might be that if people get high,
they're drinking less,
spending less gambling,
less.
You want to hear irony,
one of the chairman's,
uh,
one of the commissioners for the Nevada state athletic commission,
his company that he owns,
applied for a medical marijuana license.
Whoa,
that's awesome.
Yeah.
His name is able to dig into this.
His name is a commissioner
mel and his company applied for a marijuana distributor dispensary license last
year.
Not that,
how about that?
How about that?
Your twats perfect.
Alright folks,
uh,
unbox therapy is on youtube and it's fucking fantastic.
A red band on twitter.
Go to [inaudible] dot tv for all the information regarding still deaths.
Quite a tv [inaudible] dot tv.
All the information about tomorrow night show at standing up live.
Tony hinchcliffe,
I go to naca.
Shouldn't be a fucking bang up.
Fun time.
Oh yeah,
it's gonna.
Be fun.
Always fun.
Um,
and lewis is unbox therapy on twitter and this weekend shows almost sold out in
vancouver and calgary.
There's only a handful of tickets left for calgary,
but I'm there friday and saturday with the golden pony,
aka tony hinchcliffe,
and I'll be back tomorrow with dr chris rollins.
So until then,
bye bye.